[Music]
welcome
everybody to the wild card round of the
bull chest championship presented by
susquehanna international group grand
master robert hess alongside me today
as always is grandmaster ahmad hamilton
amman we have some serious matchups in
store for everybody
how excited for you for this to begin
well
robert it's good to be back uh today and
the rest of the week people have a lot
of bullet checks to look forward to
if you felt spoiled during the pretty
intense qualifiers
that uh you and i got a chance to
commentate along with danny ranch
uh believe me it's only gonna get better
from here because there are so many
strong players
in those tournaments i'd like to think
that we found the best players
from the qualifying bracket and we've
brought them here for the wild card
today
we certainly have and let's remind
everybody what the format is it has
changed from the qualifier
to this wild card round it is a 12
player bracket overall the top four
players
have a buy into the quarterfinals and
we will have matches of 30 minutes this
time
there will be a break after 15 minutes
the players can regain their composure
and then they'll get right back in the
chess board for one minute but zero
second increment chess
and if the match is tied after those 30
minutes we get a sudden death where the
higher seed gets the white pieces first
the prize money amman it's pretty
generous considering this is a bullet
chess event first place
10 grand hey robert that's that's not
too bad for
what most people would call a pretty
pretty easy day's
day's work i mean these are your regular
bullet players playing a lot of
one-minute chess
on chess.com and without increment dirty
flagging for money count me in robert
absolutely and it is going to be very
stressful even if it's quick chess i
mean just one minute per side
there will be that dirty flag zaman just
highlighted and let's talk about who
we'll be doing
said flagging because we have our 12
participants
you will notice on the top right of the
bracket there eric henson has replaced
dimitron draken he was not available
to compete for this so we have a last
second replacement
and is none other than your chest pro
partner eric hanson so mon when
you look at this bracket who do you see
as the favorites in today's match-ups
which are arjun ira gacy that's our
first one against levon aronian we will
have vladimir temiev taking on raunek
sedwani
we have eric hanson taking on minlae and
we have niall sarah taking on bortnick
so who are your favorites in those four
matches
well i think the most important thing is
establishing that eric is indeed awake
uh can't be the favorite in the match if
you're not actually there so i think
there's signs of life
and eric is indeed up and ready to go uh
the good thing for eric i would say
if you're going to come into a last
minute replacement at least it's a very
familiar opponent
wonderful time eric hanson they've
played so many games on chess.com so
that'll be sort of your your classic
like streamer matchup
i know they've played tons and tons of
games and of course i'm most excited to
see
levon aronian because you know levon
aronian vlad artemyev these are
these are names that we didn't see in
the actual uh qualifiers robert that's
right and lavonne
he is one of the best players in the
world we know that in classical chess
and an over-the-board chess but we don't
get to see him play bullet chest that
often he does play
in the speed chess championships and
other events but it's a rare sight to
have lavon
for taking in such an event so we'll see
if argentina can
knock him out before he can even face
hikaru nakamura so
let's remind everybody of the schedule
because today is the wild card round you
see
in front of you you know what time it is
it's right now tomorrow will be the
quarterfinals that is april 6th starting
at a little bit later hour
so that's good for you and i am on we're
going to be happy to start a bit later
and then wednesday will be the semis and
finals 9am pacific
and then finally we have the all-star
showdown on thursday that will be a lot
of fun featuring
the likes of the botez sisters maurice
ashley nemo and others it will be a
really really fun event coming your way
this thursday but today up next is
arjun aragasi taking on levon aronian
um amman i really don't know who to pick
because arjun known as gandhivom
on chess.com he's really a beast
he is and we've seen that in the the
qualifying stage
i mean there's a there's a reason that
uh the players who
are in the qualifying stage are here
right now and that's because they
survived
not only 20 rounds against some of the
best bullet players in the world
on chess.com um but he's also you know
qualified through the ko brackets 1v1
matches so
all these players 100 deserve to be here
and lavon as you mentioned is
people don't know him in this you know
one minute time controls much even scc
he gets that extra
second when he's playing his bullet
chest so this is a really exciting
matchup between
someone that people have seen a lot of
in the last week
qualifying through the the brackets that
is arjun
versus lavonne who everyone knows but we
haven't seen a lot of his
uh pure bullet chest so i'm super
excited for this well hopefully he is a
top-notch mouse because he will need
every second against a player as strong
as argentina gazi and we are about to
have lift up but before we do
let's give a shout out to the sponsors
of this bullet chest championship
presented by sig
big shout out to the presenting partner
susquehanna
international group is a global
quantitative trading firm that uses
strategic games like chess
to improve their decision-making skills
and one of the largest proprietary
trading firms in the world
thank you so much for sponsoring this
event and we are excited
to have liftoff in the playoff stage it
is the wildcard round and it will be
arjun aragasi versus levana ronin the
winner gets to play hikaru nakamura the
reigning champion in bullet chess hero
chess.com and also the player who was
taking
down all the qualifiers and showing his
might we know how good he is
and we'll see if the winner of this
match even has a chance
in the quarterfinals against hikaru yeah
i mean you almost said it like it was a
like it was a prize there for a second
robert
the winner of this match gets to play
hikaru
i mean hitara waiting for you in the
next round i'm not sure what that does
to your uh to your confidence there but
at the end of the day a match against
the ikar nakamura would always be
in everyone's best interest here we go
robert the games are off
oh gosh in the bottom learning playing
opening i don't think we would see him
play in classical chess he has the c5
and e5 pawns locked center he will need
to strike with f5 later in the game to
have any sort of counter play
yeah this is the thing about bullet
chests especially 1-0 and i
emphasize uh no increment as uh closed
positions
are often a lot more common even by the
the top top players
and look at this h5 he takes an f4 he's
going to take the spawn h5
so levon drops a pawn but opens up the
king side so here comes rook h8
pawn g4 and will we see a quick
checkmate for black or will white's
extra material tell the tale
yeah i wasn't sure if black was going to
be interested in some sort of blockade
instead um he's wow this position is
opening up here so like you said
somebody's gonna be in trouble here i
think that white objectively
should be happy but with no time on the
clock looking at this g4 square
and that's why arjun puts his knight on
g4 but levon says
no no no you're not locking this thing
up i'm going to get g4 and soon
yeah and i think rook d8 and then g4 is
a nice
uh move in between so you don't allow
knight e4
exactly that's what we're seeing here at
f3 he didn't even play g4 he goes f3
because h3 is
a vulnerable pawn so what about just
like queen to h6 or queen of queen f5
even better so you can take an x3
with the queen and go in for checkmate
yep nope be careful that rook is sliding
over to h6 and we might even see as
robert pointed out something like queen
takes h3
oh oh and there it goes rook takes h3
first step one you can't take well you
can't take him into the pawn but you
have to sacrifice you're working f3 just
next and that second rook is coming no
this has to be winning take more gauge
six
yep here it comes looks very very good
oh a great defensive move below by
arguing queen b3
amazing wow oh no that's not what you
want if you're lavon time scramble
against someone as strong as argentina
gacy no way
no he has to be happy with how that game
went but he let it slip
when he needed to convert he needed rook
h6 before
uh queen f3 well you know the
action happened so quickly barely have a
chance to show you what it will be maybe
we'll have a chance later but right now
lavon doing his best
he's keeping pace on the clock he's
pushed his pawn all the way up here and
now it's an
even rook end game and levant speed is
impressing me right now
it is this is very solid i mean after
are we gonna see the full flag probably
the rooks get traded and there they go
a draw to start things off and with that
brand new account
levon oroni and uh getting in about 60
61 points for a draw not bad
we'll take those points we don't mind
that and lavon going for this ultra
solid london type of setup that now is
transitioned into a caracon
uh kind of with the pawn structure and i
like it i think it's a good strategy for
levon but he's already down five seconds
in the opening
yeah and that's meaningful it might
might seem like nothing even taking that
one two extra seconds to get the game
underway but it all
it all adds up right at the end of the
the time scramble
it does but i like his position here the
light squares are weak for black over
there on the king side here's queen d3
and after f5
that e5 square is very weak and white
can
use it to his advantage what do you
think about lavon taking that
beep on in in about half a second i
would have a lot more deliberation
before
opening up my entire queen side for the
rooks
i have to admit lavon has always been a
fascinating player to watch a very brave
player
and yeah you're essentially allowing
arjun to do to you what you did to him
in the previous game go for the attack
despite being down material
oh but the queen came back after f4 and
there's going to be a mate on the light
squares there must be
yeah this is absolutely not what arjun
wanted and
as we see he's just gonna continue with
uh f takes g3 because
he can't stop queen h7 and here comes
rook g1 and
rook takes g7 and oh no this is going
badly for argent here but he showed
great defense in game one
we'll see if somehow he can miraculously
survive this yep and he's doing his best
impression right now rook to b7
uh king to e8 he's gonna run that king
and that's what he's doing right now
queen takes f1 there was queen d6 there
but he decided to
take it didn't want to fall for rook g8
exactly they were in the swap in
virginia anyway so at least he gets a
rook and a piece and there's
this king on c2 rookie 2 check coming
yep white has to be quick quintix e6
probably works
because that king on c7 is also
extremely vulnerable yeah
something like knight v8 needed which is
not the move you want because queen e5
is going to pick off the rook
and levon's ahead on the clock so he
started off down five seconds
and ever since that moment he's played
great chess and he's up on time but he
lost his rook there and now he doesn't
have too much material to deliver
checkmate so he needs to be very quick
he does and as long as he you know
advances the pawns
uh with pre-move stays on the light
squares he should be good here he not
only has the knight but he has the queen
against the rook and that is going to be
enough lavon aronian
3 200 already and a first lead in this
match early on robert what do you make
of lavon's playing bullet
he's been very impressive honestly
playing better than i thought he would
however he can't count his blessings
just yet he's only up one game this is
30 minutes total a bullet and arjun ira
gacy is an
absolute beast so look at this opening
which i've
been fond of lately where you sacrifice
your b-pawn because you've already
taken the c pawns you get the activity
for black well in 62 check
but isn't it just queen b1 that was uh
necessary after bishop b7 i feel like
he's
dead lost here but my theory could be a
little off
you're you're absolutely correct and
arjun went wrong here by bringing his
queen to the kings it made sense to go
for the attack unfortunately
the fork on c2 he missed it and now he's
just gonna resign
and i think that's smarter like if if
the opening doesn't go your way
playing against lavon irony and you
don't need to prove anything by playing
on you're just going to be wasting
uh time on the clock then you're going
to need back
well now that i was losing a second game
in a row i would have considered
actually running more clock to gather
myself it's very difficult to play
bullet game after bullet game
when you don't have time to recover and
right now this is an interesting line
against the london system where the
knight has gone to feed keto on g7 but
that knight's coming right out to f5 and
watch out for
white center's already collapsed yeah i
mean this
is queen takes d5 obviously we can see
the the easy moves for white knight e4
rookie one rook d1
i actually don't mind this in in a
bullet sense because that bishop on c8
is just not playing the game
i wouldn't mind it except for the fact
that arjun's playing very quickly so
out of the gates origin of the time
avenger but this is the second game in a
row or maybe the third game
where arjun gets really quickly out of
the opening but unfortunately for him
he's in a tougher position
so he starts spending his time yeah and
i mean this is just
easy tactics for lavon oh queen c3
queensy seven check
that's unbelievable
that's beautiful but argent fighting f2
square is a problem
yeah oh maybe rook a2 to a7
that looked good but now bishop's coming
to d5 the g2 pawn could be under attack
and those and b
pawns i think black is now ahead i think
black's just better
and the problem was that a pawn look at
these pawns they snuck up to b5 a5 a4
they're all on light squares can be
protected bishop c4
and you need to get that rook in the
game like rook d queen e5 though
oh yeah network d8 yeah bring that
rotation
how did you let that uh turn around so
quickly i think he just
lost sight of the rook infiltrating he
should have put his bishop in front of
the bishop d5 bishop c4 things like that
keep that rook out of the game and
here's rook f8 and lavon
i honestly still worked left because
he's up a queen there's no checkmate
anytime soon so he needs to play quickly
yeah and g4 that's that's really big for
arjun's position
if he can trade one of these pawns queen
f8 is huge though
he hasn't nice and take the pawn g4 oh
he's done queen
takes
and levon didn't move are we sure he's
live on camera right now
oh my goodness and that's what happens
in bullet the more you defend the more
resourceful you are
arjun is amazing at defense and that is
why he won that game he just did not
allow himself to lose and you know not
that lavon doesn't know this but i'm
gonna harp
on one of the most basic bullet skills
that you should have which is that
when your opponent has a bishop you
always move on the opposite color square
that's just uh a way to avoid blunders
like these not like lavon doesn't know
that but
an oversight under time pressure there
and
you see moves to a light square
immediately loses the queen
wow wow and look at this tactic knight
takes d4 because the bishop one h5 is
hanging so
lavon loses a pawn here arjun playing
very tenaciously
and takes the pawn moves his bishop back
and look at those pawns b4 to d4
yeah the knight on a4 is really poorly
placed right now it can always be
supported by an eventual b5 but
i think this is concerning and look at
that move brook e3 says no queen trade
for you
no i'm just going to double on the e
file maybe push not maybe definitely
push d5
and white has an adventure but lavon
doing well on the clock arjun
and and him they both about the same
time watch out for the background
checkmate so he plays g6
yeah no then this knight on a4 is a big
big issue right now
pawn on c6 looks weak okay but here
comes the wrap around knight d5 just
causing some problems here and there and
now h5 i'm just pushing that pawn
hitting that queen
yeah and let's not forget the night on
c2 now is the knight that's not so good
on the board he used to be black's
knight but levon did a great job
rerouting
yeah this knight e6 actually kind of
contains that knight on c2 can't get
into the d4 square
and now a5 that's what i'm going for
trying to break that pawn chain on the
queen side
and black's position is so solid here um
everything's protected it seems knight
e3
knight f5 is the idea oh knight five
walks right into it
oh both players missed it uh
is their knight f5 again no there's rook
g4 it doesn't work
oh queen f6 though there's a point of
six the rook's pinned he can't play
rookie seven to protect
goodness and now queen f7 this has to be
a win just easily
just don't blunt her hang on rook h4 is
coming oh i was just too clean with the
execution of checkmate there
queen e8 rook f7 queen h8 did not even
give black
enough did he didn't just win the piece
to win the game he saw that forced me
and that was that was good technique
and just like that the match is tied two
and a half two and a half we have
just four minutes about 45 seconds
remaining in the first half they'll take
a break after that
and then they will play 15 more minutes
of bullets so the nerves might be there
but arjun
he's gathered himself he is now tied in
this match and with the black pieces in
this one
he's trying to collapse white center
yeah and i think that
usually the player that you know
leslie's more of a natural bullet player
tens in my experience take a little bit
more time warming up so to speak
a guy like lavonne i think he's going to
be fresher early or a guy like arjun i
think he needs to warm up to bullet
um and we're starting to see that right
now how relevant is that
blunder of the queen gonna be in this
match yeah we'll
come back to haunt him and right now the
position is locked up black is up a pawn
but knight d4 says hey your bishop's on
b5 it's not really moving anywhere the
cease
okay well now it's definitely it's gone
i'm not sure about that decision but i
see what lavon's point is
easy play for white more difficult play
psychologically for black
rook to c1 or rook to b1 which am i
going to go for and here goes rook c1 to
try to push to c6
right now the you know the pawns are
sort of oriented in a way and i love the
movie h5 the pawns are oriented in a way
that the black
uh bishop bishop for arjun here is going
to be better in an end game
than lavon's but levon put that pawn on
h5 now he's got the g file
and i think in bullet and you're
penetrating from all sides really tough
to handle
yeah and black's up a pawn but that
extra pawn is kind of useless right now
the pawn on d5 is blockaded and now the
king's in c6 you need to infiltrate both
sides need to play move like f5 or
something like that to go in and here's
rook g8 could start
maybe there's rookie j rook h7 just to
be a bit tricky queen
a5 oh and here comes the queen h4 maybe
there it is
yeah and both sides are infiltration but
the
problem for black is you only have the
queen there once all these pieces like
rook takes a fate with queen d6 check to
come
this is dangerous yeah but i i think
realistically
uh there should oh king b4 a5
it's safe and queenie six check and pawn
666 ponzi six
and the king can walk in as well oh my
gosh you take enough date with check and
that's mate and so levon ironian
strikes back that was a king walk and
then
you can't handle that no i mean we were
wondering hey who's going to have the
safer king well it's actually weiss king
was safer because it's going to black
side of the board
unreal those dark squares under white's
control there so safe king and that was
your queen trade this looks awkward for
white
you can't castle knight c6 comes you're
gonna drop the e5 pawn yeah so
i think black's better ah this is
typical bullet stuff
even if you don't win that pawn back on
e5 the games where you can just look at
these
look at the development here it's just
amazing anytime you can do this in
bullet rod it's almost always good for
black
and black is down on time though so it
feels good and it's one of those
things you thought that black would be
playing instantly every turn but levon
showing that lack of experience in
bullet chess and so he does take his
time he gets good positions but then he
has to prove them against the speedster
that is arjun irigase
g3 not a big fan of i don't really know
why we needed to play g3
maybe he was looking at the f4 square in
a position like this but
uh f5 f4 is powerful stuff from leblanc
yeah it looks like there are many moves
here that should be good he just goes f4
straight forward yeah knight h3 all
right so how do you actually
pile up pressure on that pin piece i
just made a draw you just make it draw
robert
okay no no no pressure the pressure's
off i'm just gonna
agree to split the point there and all
right now we have a french 94 look at
that he caught him he caught him
pre-moving
oh my gosh arjun caught levon pre-moving
so the funny thing about positions like
this is sometimes
you're not even happy with what you end
up getting your queen's on h1 you're
gonna you know it's bullet you're gonna
have to
reroute a little bit obviously a nice
little bullet trick there
as 94. these are our favorite tricks
robert they're not blunders
they're fine moves anyway maybe not the
best but you know you're not you're not
concerned if they get
caught exactly and lavon you know
anticipating a
normal french defense and that's why
argent 94
catching him off guard so he won in
exchange but this is not easy the dark
squares
are under white's control they're
playing on opposite the board and f4
that's a very very
very good move sacrificing pawn for the
square and now i think white's
position's about to fall apart
yeah it should just be over here take on
e3 take on f4
um and i think he has to trade queens
try to go knight e2 but
uh he forgot the g pawn and that's
that's probably close to resignable yeah
rook and two pawns
for just a knight and this is just easy
at this point
yep arjun's the one up on the clock and
that really was a nice move f4
the the idea of like i don't have any
space for my queens and rooks
and you have to have open lines if you
even want your material advantage to be
felt in that case
rooks need open space and look at now
there's a knight hanging nice h4 giving
up the palm for the night that is a
resignation
and wait is there time for one more that
was not like a buzzer beater
oh but it seems like we are at the break
and it is a 4-4 tie amon
i don't know i've been excited by this
match i've been impressed by both
players first bit lavon jumping out to
that lead
and then for arjun to bounce back
against levon ronin
what do you make as we head to break i i
think we are
truly seeing a an incredibly close match
um not one that i think is gonna be a
blow in either direction
lavon has clearly shown that he has the
speed i mean we've both been impressed
by it
and arjun took a little bit of time to
warm up but i feel like he's finding his
rhythm here so four to four going into
the break
especially this is only the first match
of the day robert this is just a great
sign for what we have in store
i do think the break comes at a bad time
for arjun it feels like he's had the
momentum
however that's part of the rules we are
going to take this break and when
returned there will be more
from the bullet chest championship
presented by sig
i got into playing poker in college and
really liked it but
never considered i could make a career
out of it until jeffy ass came and gave
a talk at harvard
jeff explained that yes you can actually
use gaming skills for your career and
for something to do on a day-to-day
basis which was
exciting at the time i thought it was
really cool we can pretty much guarantee
you that we'll give you the best
education you will be taught all that we
know
in a very professional manner by expert
teachers and
you're going to be mentored and i like
to think that there's no other place
where you can get as much mentorship as
you can
at susquehanna i think that the main
thing that everybody has in common is
a sense of competitiveness and interest
in gaming and
strategy in general i would say you're
you're playing a game as a career
it's very satisfying to me that we've
been able to employ so many people
give them not just an opportunity to
make a lot of money but to be with the
smartest people in the world
and to have a lot of fun and make a lot
of friends and create a culture
of reason
[Music]
and we returned ready for more exciting
bullet chess here
among that first half four to four i
couldn't even get out of my seat i was
still so jittery from it
what do you think had happened in the
second half now the players had a break
they got used to each other's styles
is it going to be lavon is it going to
be arjun what's your take
well i think that uh you mentioned the
jitters yourself that's just in the
commentary booth i think that the
players probably had
some similar sentiment because look at
lavon blundering a queen
something you you know do not expect
from a player of his caliber that's just
getting used to bullet getting used to
the format as we see the games are
underway
and meanwhile arjun i mean he probably
just uh hasn't played any bullet at all
in the first bullet games of the day
you're going to play levon ronian i
think it takes some time to get used to
that
i agree with you there and look at this
black has won a pawn but white
sacrificed it to gain the center here
there's two pawns there e and d pawns
for white only one for black
and so a spatial advantage for white but
does it offset the material of mine
i'm not sure usually centers like this i
am too nervous about them collapsing to
the likes of the move c5
or something like that what we see c5
right away i would have tried to put
more pressure on the e pawn but the idea
is the same he wants to target
the e5 pawn now that white's played d5
and look at this the knight on h5 will
be captured and can't be captured twice
but the knight
c3 is hanging right now that's why 94
was thrown in and
lavon quickly brings that knight back
but it's just one extra pawn for black
the pawns are not very good c5 is weak
uh there's some activity for white with
the bishop pair but i think all things
considered levon should be happy to get
to this point
agree i was going to say rook b8 and the
rook has no choice but
really to allow this exchange the
knight's going to come back into the
game all the way to e8 and f6
uh if possible wow what a great call
knight c798 here comes knight f6
and there's no attack for white you
don't have enough pieces here and that
bishop on e5 is a hero
it is threatening mating ideas you can
trade off and bishop before at any point
and it protects all around the board is
there like bishop h6 is there some sort
of crazy move like that i don't think it
quite worked there
it didn't and now you definitely can't
do it anymore bishops are off the board
now 94
look at that dark square control don't
blunder f7 do not blunder that pawn
but arjun is ahead of the clock right
and that's increasingly relevant here is
we see uh
uh the really tough position for him but
if you're going to be in a tough
position
may as well be ahead on the clock give
yourself a fighting chance in bullets oh
but look at this the attack is coming
next
three and the quench one mate can't stop
it that's yeah pre-move you can't stop
it
impossible an actual pre-movement yes
bishop e2 that's the that's what an
experienced bullet player might do if uh
you know if there was lower time let's
say but obviously lavon has that game in
the bag
he comes back from the break robert and
immediately uh makes a statement with a
win like that
yeah that's huge because he's up a point
there under 13 minutes remaining in the
match clock
and reminder to everybody as long as the
final game there's
one second five seconds on the clock
that last game goes and so you will have
to keep our eyes on that but right now
arjun playing a solid approach
against lundstrom with the black pieces
i'm worried about black's king though
arjun playing on the queen side but when
all said and done and the king side
opens up do you have enough pieces there
to protect your king
yeah and i was gonna say this is usually
really tough to handle moves like bishop
h4
um you've got like g4 g5 happening queen
h3
is usually the really uh common
follow-up move but
uh the queen side is opening up quicker
than expected actually
yeah because white also took on b4 i
wasn't expecting all that but i guess
there was no real choice
some of the lines had to open up and he
trades on d7 now he doesn't have an
attack because that bishop is needed to
attack the h7 square and the light
squares
this is a very interesting battle yeah
and i love how quickly
uh lavon was able to transition from you
thought this would be like a
you know headless chicken attack all the
way to oh let's just
win a pawn slide the rook over to c2
double the rooks and he's just playing
chess again
but arjun is up six seven seconds here
and i think it's
easier to play with the time advantage
although without safety for the king
uh maybe i spoke too soon here go down
goes the f7 pawn
robert he's just like 50 50 between
queen side and king side
those three pieces are doubling and
tripling on both sides of the board
and here's trade off the rooks but now
rook c8 okay the d4 pawn hangs
and this is going to be a time scramble
because white is up a pawn
and much better yet without the time on
the clock perhaps arjun can now play him
here
look at this knight though completely
stuck you just like you just walk the
the king up it feels like okay he's done
just that and
wrote 95. what an amazing amazing move
wow but look at arjun he's still heading
the clock
yeah i feel like this one has got to be
uh lavon's game but let's just
see exactly when you judge someone's
speed it's positions like this
oh no he's got 2.7 seconds left take the
pawn take the pawn okay he can't lose
but he's not winning no no i told you
yeah you know you called it you called
it oh man arjun too quick
and lavon trying his best here but
that's not going to do the trick
and arjun irigasey there how do you
survive that
i i think that's um not
well okay i'll be blunt i don't think
that's anything to do with his skill
there
uh i think that was lavon just not being
experienced enough in bullet to convert
that
something like four to five seconds with
a position with
extra rook and bishop that you can
pre-move is is just
uh i mean arjun did well but i don't
think he it was amazing defense
i think that should be a win for for
lavon's position every time
okay well speaking of wins and the
position i like lebron's position here
especially after the f3 move just
retreat your bishop you have the bishop
pair no weaknesses in blacks camp the e2
pawn is a backward pawn
can be attacked later in the game and
wow lebron just trades there and plants
the bishop on e5 takes over the dark
squares
yeah and these positions are always so
unpleasant for white because
opposite bishops so easy to make these
pre-moves and these these pawns are so
uncomfortable
i mean king g7 just feels so solid for
lavon but
i'm impressed by how white is playing
this yeah look at the speed
up now 10 seconds is arjun just take on
e6 you can
i think you can start trying to flag him
that would be my mindset in games not
even
you want to play good chess of course
but just make it interesting keep pieces
on the board and make it as difficult
for levon as possible because he's shown
in time travel he may not have the speed
to match up with argentinerige here
yeah and be careful because oh man
bishop e6 is coming h6 if king g7 maybe
f4 so many things happening at once yeah
actually he should have taken on g6 and
put his queen on h6 so the king couldn't
get to g7 but either way
this is still looking very promising for
what just taken okay
bishop f5 wins the g6 pawn
oh my gosh textbook oh my gosh take an
f6
h6 bishop e4
i don't know if he's gonna win on the
board anymore but he's going to win on
the clock yeah
i i just yeah as you said just take the
queens here
no need to uh to sugarcoat it this this
looks like a
very easy win for white yeah well now
she's winning on the board because the
king
went all over the place to take him with
d4 don't allow the pawn to queen and
that's game down yeah that d-pawn will
go bishop covers c2
and obviously in a position like this
you never want to pre-move as white
you just don't want to allow that c2 c1
uh trick so you're up
that much time that much on position
take your time no need to pre-move and
take the point home
and arjun just playing to his strength
right now lavon has the white side here
he's gonna try to play
a nice game he's been playing
technically very sound chest
yes bit too slow he's taking a little
bit too much time
yep that's uh one way to put it but if i
had to
tell you how these matches were going to
go that's exactly what i would have told
you coming into the event we expect that
from this match that lavon is not going
to be as experienced with the speed
but he's such a technically you know
beautiful player that
that's how he's going to get his wins
he's going to be a little bit slower but
he's going to
compensate with the moves on the board
look at this position for what you
couldn't dream of a better position
the bishop pair his pawn on d6 a thorn
in black side
uh no real active play for black all the
pawns control the black pieces
so look at that just gonna win the c5
pawn rook a5 not exactly the move you
want to play but it holds everything
together for the time being
right and b3 takes takes i mean white's
position is super solid but i was about
to say that
d-pawn is falling you know and by the by
the same
at the same time the c-pawn is and so
now black is up upon
lavon trying to open up the king's side
for those bishops and he's doing just
that i put h5
and g5 push those pawns through but
arjun once again with the very sturdy
defense
and he's up on the clock such an
impressive game like uh he's up 10
seconds here
we were saying it's the best position
levon could dream of and all of a sudden
that's it it's over should we start d6
oh then the bishop's hanging though oh
so now bishop d6 i mean
bishop c6 was needed oh okay so
what's the end game here looks good for
white just push the b pawn
don't fall into a fork yeah i'm trying
to think what
what that working uh position would be
here
yeah i don't see one oh but the king get
out that's huge showing bishop
seven rather than bishop e3 yep yep this
is not good that knight is going to be
really tricky to deal with
and you can't even take the pawns no
arjun is going to oh
tk6 bishop six did you have six yeah
oh my gosh he gets the pawn and it's
wrong yeah the queen doesn't matter at
that point
no chance for lavon to win that game so
he did all that he
needed to do just get that pawn off the
board that was like a 15 to 20 second
time advantage near the end
and what's so ironic about that is you
think when you're punching some time you
need to play quickly to flag your
opponent what arjun should have done
is think for a couple seconds to figure
out a way how he could have kept his g7
pawn
he's obviously losing at that point but
you keep the pawn so you can win on time
100 yep and whoa
it's a free piece oh
that was just a free piece an opening
trick for levon ronin and arjun walks
right into it
yeah that was the that was the weirdest
thing but i don't know if it was when
he's just gonna resign
holy that's the that's the best possible
thing that could have happened to
levon aronian with the bounce-back win
absolutely and i think from arjun that's
smart you're looking at the match clock
just over five minutes left you need to
get as many games as possible when
you're down when you're thinking about
it i have a deficit
lavon is objectively the stronger player
but in bullet arjun has shown his
prowess he's showing his quick skills
his resourcefulness and now i think with
the black pieces here well this is as
good a position as you could ask for the
opening
yeah i was about to say f5 is the move
that is really going to cement the
advantage and lavon plays c4
for good reason if black got to play c4
there i think the game might just be
simply over
yeah now bishop c4 you get a quick
counter play you need to open up the
position there's a king on e8
knight c4 here it comes knight you won't
play 95 you can't because the knight's
there
maybe i'll take on c6 at some point and
try for 95 but wait
i did not love that decision by lavon no
he seemed like
yeah at this point lavon is uh doing
what we call a bullet ascending it
yes and king he said what a calm move
what a great move and now that 96 is
hanging it might have to go back e3 is
hanging with check
now this is this is the trading queens
look at that play by origin
yeah that's that is really really good
stuff rook c2
um rook c5 probably even even smarter
and here comes rookie two so he
takes the rook off the open file puts it
behind the pawn and so good
just resigns and there's a reason that
lavon resigned that game for the
almost exact same reason that arjun
resigned the last game you might think
oh
down a piece versus down a single pawn
that's not even close to the same thing
but
the way that arjun played that game
there's no counter play he knows that
arjun's a faster bullet player in time
scrambles
and and he's ahead on position as well
so he i think made the good decision to
give that game up
i agree with you and i'm looking three
minutes and 40 seconds remaining so
we could just have a couple more games
left and now it's an aggressive approach
for black you're missing that light
square bishop's like oh bishop g4 you
got to get that bishop to e6 just take
over the light squares
yeah absolutely agree that that was uh
something that lavon allowed but only
briefly he's not going to let that
happen again as we see
a quote-unquote free pawn but uh i feel
like nothing is
nothing is ever totally free there's
going to be a lot of counter play oh
yeah
down the open f file the good thing for
white is having the bishop pair
and the kink is you know relatively safe
for now but i love this movie
hx no f4 for you and the knight on e7 is
the problematic piece you need to be
able to improve that one
and yeah he's just going to try to
double the rooks rook f7 rook f8
um and then go from there something like
g5 and knight
e7 at g6 looks like something for the
future
absolutely it's a better position for
black based on the strategy
but white is upon look at this bishop on
e2 it's pretty much useless against the
dark square control that levon has
yeah this is a gorgeous position
probably uh you know
longer time control as well but in
bullet to have the knights here is just
a privilege and the knights are not
going anywhere that's the problem is
all of these whites spawn uh from you
know b3 to d5 back to f3 they take away
all the knight squares and now f4 at
long last
yeah and you don't care about losing
losing the rook on g5
well now you might because i can take on
f1 first and then
take on g5 well what's happening that's
just a bullet move for you
something to throw you off oh rook f2
because the rook kind of fade
discover check andy takes on e6 that was
beautiful
but time look at the time eight seconds
for lavon he needs to checkmate him
quickly
yep knight in okay good start knight
takes h4 now knight f3 check was a
threat
brook f2 oh knight g2 that can't be
right can it recap
oh rook f2 is needed there
okay queen d7 king h6 one second left
one second he's not gonna get time he's
on time take the phone
oh my gosh he barely made the draw that
was unbelievable
wow what a heads heads-up play from
levon hey you guys can look at the same
game as us and say look
lavon is too slow for this but he is
making it work with the skills that he
has he's winning on the board
and when he does have these slow games
he is securing draws
out of absolutely nowhere which is just
as impressive as those times scramble
wins
and it is seven half seven half we only
have a minute 15 seconds left so if
i blunder a piece i'm resigning at the
snap of my fingers because you get that
one more game in so you need to be aware
of the match clock if you're both these
players i like what arjun is doing right
now he is just
pressing forward on the queen side there
is no king side attack
this is looking good for argentina right
now
yeah i mean talk about a kingside attack
it might be black who's playing on both
sides of the board here
yes and b3 probably a good decision just
to lock things up the knight needs to
get active knight to
d3 at some point but the bishop is
coming to b2 oh
that bishop's in there and it's just a
thorn in white side
yeah i feel like i might have traded the
rooks in that position although
tough tough to make that uh decision
quickly this looks like
an absolutely crushing game for arjun
here i would consider resigning this
i know how like ridiculous that sounds
but it looks so bad for white
and objectively the position is terrible
that i would think i'm resigning to
conservative 20 seconds to get one more
game
that's crazy decisions like that are so
tough to make in the match uh situation
and as soon as they say rook a6 happens
and what's better like rook takes e6
it's happening like
it's unbelievable what happens in bullet
games yep yep
b4 b5 also uh ready to happen
oh well i don't know what that means wow
okay
give some pawn queen h3 yeah
yeah knight f1 back the knights hanging
on d6 and rooks hd6 would be would have
been threatened by knight five
that was not a good choice keep in mind
the bishop might sneak in like bishop c1
uh right when you least expect it like
right now right now good call
i think that this is just arjun's game
yeah this is just the final bullet game
it's going to come down to this it's all
decided by this right here great move
knight g4 the knight six is a threat
and there it is and then we can't go to
a7 that's important
gotta take it no d6 okay d5 and rookie
seven check freaking sim check
arjun's playing slowly yeah e6
oh my gosh they're both in time trouble
take the queen and just that's a really
smart decision i think
he knows he can flag uh lavon here i
don't know
let's go oh what a move oh my gosh
i think argent has it but barely yeah i
think he's got it but barely
oh my goodness and that's exactly what
happened he has it but
barely and he has that match in his
pocket but
that was maybe the closest match you
might see in this competition robert you
couldn't ask for a closer match he won
with one point
whatever seconds left and that is the
match
arjun aragaisi moves on to take on
hikaru nakamura
amman we're both impressed by levana
running out of the gates
and he still had many good positions but
the speed
of arjun gacy earns him that match
wow i don't even know what to say like
if if uh
you know we're doing the call and you
sort of have the players and their skill
sets mapped out against one another
it's almost fitting that the match came
down to
this which is just a time scramble it
simply was arjun was just that little
bit more comfortable
in every single time scramble and that's
the reason why he won this match as we
see in the final game
it was just about time scramble ability
and he was that a little bit better than
lavonna ronin in that category
well we are going to go on a quick break
and when we return we will bring arjun
on for an interview
we'd love to hear his thoughts so stay
tuned everybody we'll be back shortly
for more from the bullet chess
championship presented by sign
and we are back joined by arjun irigase
this is uh an amazing way to start this
bullet
chess championship wild card day arjun
i'm gonna go straight to you with
i mean what did you expect from lavon
since not a lot of us know
about his bullet chest whereas we've
seen you in the qualifiers throughout
the last week
i i just wanted to learn from him it's
such a pleasure thing playing against
him
in any format of the game absolutely and
you know you showed your might and i
have to ask you about the one moment i
think turned the match
when he played queen f7 check and you
took his queen you were down two and a
half half of that point
how happy were you you didn't show it on
camera very much but how happy were you
internally when you were able to take
his queen and then turn the match around
internally i was very very happy very
believe that
that i got rid of the small deal
yeah i think i think that that moment
for us was like a really big one in the
entire match
um in terms of maybe match strategy uh
i think you'll probably be the first one
to say that you know
flagging from from your perspective is a
skill that you probably have a little
bit better than lavon is that something
you were
looking to utilize in this match when it
came down to just the seconds you were
feeling confident there
yeah the whole match i just banged on it
pretty much
i think you should give yourself more
credit you played some really great
chess
i mean that last game with the black
pieces you were outplaying him for
the majority of it you're pushing down
the queen side and yeah of course
something went a little wrong at some
point but you did a great job
of playing on both sides of the board so
how do you balance that because i know
that something i struggle with
is determining when to just play very
quickly or when to prioritize to stop
for a few seconds
and try to figure out the position more
objectively
it was a very top-sector victim and i
actually messed it up i was worse
yeah that stuff kind of happens in in
bullet
you can never really take one evaluation
and assume it's going to be the same for
the for the whole game
um another thing about bullet with that
in mind is i'm just wondering
do you feel like you're the type of
player that plays a bit better after
warming up because it felt like it was a
shaky start for you
nearly a two game lead opening up for
lavon but as the match went on it seemed
to us like you started to play a lot
better
so the first few games i didn't listen
i warmed up a bit
yeah i have a related question actually
do you sort of prepare for your
opponents
in a way because maybe it's not so much
studying their openings but is it just
seeing how
quickly they play in certain moments
like how do you get yourself ready for a
bullet chess match
as this was one just video i didn't
really prepare much i just played
what i know right yeah i mean i think in
bullet that's
probably a good strategy don't change it
up too much play with you know what
you're comfortable with
uh speaking of the uh the bracket i mean
robert and i were saying that the winner
of this match moves on to play hikaru
nakamura so
you've already touched on uh you know
what it was like to play against levon
aronian
what do you have uh have to say about
the the prospects of playing hikaru
nakamura in the next round
it's again a match where i can learn a
lot and it's a pleasure playing against
me
wow well i really appreciate this
optimistic attitude and
just the respect you have for the game
and your opponent so arjun
huge congratulations storming back from
the early deficit and defeating
such a world-class player like lavonna
roy you should be proud of yourself
everybody in the chat was really excited
about your play
thank you and there you had it you had
arjun eric icy moving on
into the quarterfinals of this bullet
chess championship presented by sig
and up next the action does not take any
break we have
vladisov artemia who played perhaps the
game of the year
recently with that queen sacrifice
delivering a checkmate
taking on the young indian talent raunak
sudwani the teenager is super strong
he is an absolute monster in bullet
chess
amman you know i always put you on the
spot as we get the players set up here
who you got in this matchup yeah that's
that's uh one of your
one of your great pleasures in
commentary robert i don't blame you for
it but
i'm gonna take the uh take the torch
here and say look i think this is gonna
be
a convincing match for artemyev that's
my gut feeling
um artemiev is an insanely strong player
in in bullet uh hands down he's like one
of the best in my opinion so
uh definitely someone to watch out for
if there's other things to
you know to say about the match i think
that there are a few
probably like nerves or maybe just
getting used to bullet that we saw
in the first match uh i think over the
course of more games
we'll start to see the the better
players shine but that's why i think
that the format chosen by chess.com
it's kind of perfect that 15 minutes
break 15 minutes
means that you don't have a lot of time
to warm up you get down two to three
games robert that could be it
that's certainly the case in many of
these matches and for artemia i will
agree with you because he is the
higher rated player in classical chats
but he also has the experience that
lavonna ronin doesn't in playing
these bullet time controls so i think
with the skill
and the speed artemium is a dangerous
opponent for anybody in the field
and it doesn't matter who he faces he
has a shot so i will give
the advantage to artemia but i will not
be surprised in the slightest
if ronaldo said one he can shrink
together a series of great bullet games
and knock out the russian superstar yeah
absolutely it is such a streaky
uh time control bullet chest we see our
time you have the players
on camera that round act by the way uh
we've seen him in the qualifiers
such a it feels like he plays with such
poise and he's not really
ever tilting when he blunders something
but you know robert every time we see
someone blunder a full queen on camera
they're never moving or flinching it's
like these guys have nerves of steel
yeah i'm here yelling at everybody
breaking their eardrums and they're just
like yeah whatever it's a typical game
of bullet
so we're off it looks like i see the
first game is just getting started here
our tamiya gets the white pieces and he
plays b3
yeah and take a look at that rating that
you see right there
uh 32 30. he's over 3 200 for a reason
we we don't see him play that much but
um he's got that rating for a reason
very very strong in in bullet chess
although this position already looks not
very good for white i have to admit and
i play a lot of b3 myself online
so if you ignore the objective
evaluation we see the bar on the screen
here
just you know we'll just look at the
position right yeah
the double pawns here obviously in
bullet that's where this is something
like this is more acceptable
when you get to longer time controls uh
you know this this would be a lot better
for black but we see that knight going
f5 robert hopping into
f3 if you don't mind yeah roundneck is
playing this perfectly he's playing on
both sides of the board his king is
going to be safe from the king side
despite the open file here
and as you said knight h4 and especially
if you take on g4 get rid of that bishop
that knight will plant itself in f3
right and he's made a decision which i
was wondering about so long term white's
going to play queen d2
bishop takes a5 that pawn cannot be
defended
you know for for a while but you can't
uh forget about the king's side both
sides winning the pawn on opposite sides
of the board
yeah and actually looks like ryan just
stole the h pawn and now has an extra
pawn there and he
exactly i don't even speak anymore you
just keep going tomorrow
well at this point i feel like ronak is
is happy
with what just happened he's obviously
got the knight against the bishop but
there's going to be quick play here for
our temiev and
up on time for round sadwani this is
probably the difference in the position
and i like what artemia did because he's
objectively in big trouble so he at
least open up the c file to go for a
counter but the queen on h2 covers the
c7 square
and that's not fake news he allowed
queen f8 and rook c8
at some moment take a g5 oh queen before
check
before check would be at least a draw
for black there
oh no this this can't be right though oh
queen b5 check queen a5
oh oh he walked into it he walked into
it it's winning the rook
and nicely done by rounding good
tactical awareness
and this chance and he's getting the pre
moves in queen e7 queen f7
and i think that is going to be the
first game wow we've we've seen uh
shaky starts from what uh who you would
think might be the
the favorites in these matches so far
yeah the higher rated players are
struggling out of the gates and looking
at their bullet ratings actually are
temmie of over
so it wasn't us just talking he has
played many bullet games
and he's over 3200 much higher rated in
bullet but not a good start
but a great start by rounding all credit
to him yep and
i was going to say bishop a6 so we do
see probably queen e1
white's gonna maybe think about playing
b3 c4 trying to lock down
both of those pieces at once
and that's why our team went knight to
d5 and there goes tonight's f4
and look how quickly run like a queen e4
lined up the c6 pawn
at some point should be captured but i
guess the b3 pawn is a weak square too
and c5 opening up that bishop on b7 and
all of a sudden
i'm starting to see those bishops come
alive oh yes they are
and with the bishop hair and plenty of
time on the clock
that should spell some trouble for white
look at the bishop one b7 happily
placed there and if you take an eight
the queen can land on eight and line
them all up
yep queen e8 great move as well heading
to c6 there's also rook
a2 a lot of lot of good pressure to put
on the position also just rook d8
trading pieces
is totally fine here and veronica voices
it but queen d7 of the d files under
blocks control queen d3 to trade the
queens
and just take over yeah queen g4 queen
h3 those type of ideas and there
there's one of them on the board right
now and he plays queen back to d1 trying
to trade the queens off he could have
put queen h3 there the jeep on sort of
pinned to the seat
i don't know see the visuals defend it
never mind i'm blundering queens
not my game it's okay so right here it
looks really good for
black up a pawn and how do you actually
make progress though
yeah after knight e4 he wants the c5
pawn and it's not the easiest thing to
stop in fact
he says look give that pawn up e4 e4
bishop g4 check
that is nice that's it sorry to cut you
off their partner but i just was
catching that
tactic as quick as uh vladislav artemyev
did and look at that
robert and uh vladislav teaming up for a
very quick win that that was a winning
tactic and he executed it
next game yep uh
everybody it is one to one we see the
scoreboard is not updated we will get
that updated as quickly as we can
but you see the score on screen in front
of you two it's one to one right now
and our channel gets the white pieces he
it's kind of like
this interesting structure where black's
king would feel a little unsafe but
now rhino is trying to keep everything
together consolidated kick white's
forces back
love this position for white um if black
ever plays c6 then the d6 pawn is so
so weak as a result and f4 for white is
often a good way to counter
the the g5 advance it's actually white
who suddenly starts playing on the
king's side
that's right and now there's a capture
on d5 and white plays that f4 both sides
could have played that four
i think rana should have gone for it
because as the position opens up look at
these light squares you don't have a
light square bishop e6 f5
that's a problem for black yeah and
that's just the the understanding to go
for f4 because you look at this epon you
might never think to do that
love the decision by ronak trying to
play on the dark squares um
often works in in bullets after check
knife three knife three make ef 3.
oh and e3's hanging yep brooke h5
he he should have taken more care of the
e3 pawn there
and still a very tricky position but the
fact that he could get rid of the
other bishop makes this a lot more
manageable if this bishop could somehow
get to d4
then we're talking but yeah that doesn't
look like it's happening any time he
lost all of his bonds
yeah rook g4 here just try to trade off
a pair of rooks that's what black wants
to do here okay rook f7 i guess
i i like that the bishop is getting f6
it's a good attempt
oh but there's queen you want check
after teenage one you can't block the
rook you lose your bishop otherwise
there's queens you want me so that's why
he brought his rook up
rook back hang on it's not so clear no
it's not clear at all
bishop 6 is such a big threat brook g6
only move
oh that i can think of yeah not tg2 and
all of a sudden it's two rooks for a
queen
and a couple pawns the rooks are so
tricky here oh it's me
oh so i think king age four
was his attempt to try to set up a
checkmate with rook f4 to f6
meet but queen e5 the perfect reaction
stops that mate and says well hang on
we're threatening checkmate i could do
that too
yeah send setting up checkmate for both
sides is what just happened and
uh here we see an early queen if i've
checked scooping up the pawn c5
ronaldoni up two games to one has the
lead in the early going still plenty of
time in this match you see on the screen
ahead of you 23 minutes in almost 30
seconds so plenty of time we'll get that
break after 15 minutes so look pretty
good at the opening for black you could
take on d3
give white's isolated pawn no weaknesses
in our 10 meters position
so far so good for him totally agree i
mean look how simple it is to play rook
d7 rook d8
just attacking uh a weak isolated pawn
in the center of the board knight d5
this is just textbook play by artemyev
right now and especially in bullet
i think this is uh even better than in a
longer time control yeah he just gives
up the rooks for the queen so it's
actually
a reverse situation now in our time
we'll have to use the queen to his
advantage but
they're a safer king for the side with a
pair of rooks so i think that
veronica's good chances yep i totally
agreed
rook takes d4 huge threat um but
tamiya is definitely gonna be aware of
that rook d7 knight takes up
six what's the i would be scared here
oh but where's the king going is king
h2q4 check
so he takes the rookie yeah there's a
draw here and i i'm looking if there's
more but i don't think so
he just takes the draw he's up two to
one he's ah why risk anything
yep both players and i don't think uh
artemia is gonna repeat exactly
what happened in game one right although
round night car has already changed it
up with g6 but you were already
highlighting
during game one how that opening didn't
work out for him
it's one of those openings you just play
for the sake of it and then you get
crushed
yeah i shouldn't do that again right
just not recommended
right and okay he's playing for an h1
knight takes g5 g5 that
yeah i think you take that and play h6
and bishop six was 94.
yep is already winning for white i'm
pretty sure
what queen g5 queen g5 knight or queen
h6
oh no i think nate oh where's the
where's the mate
where's the the knockout flow here
where's the mate how about just knight
e4 queen g5 queen takes
g6 although f4 f4 certainly looks fun
yeah he's in the castle queen side even
just
you just play yeah you can just play i
was thinking maybe f5 and knight d5
check mm-hmm that actually looked really
nice too
i'm not convinced by this no because
pawn d4 is such a
thorn for white you can't push your
e-bond you can't open up more
lines and if you you're king on c1 isn't
that safe
yeah what's going on here brook c2
though i like that maneuver
covering c3 covering b2 and making a
threat on c7
that's actually really good okay so i
would take a g6 go queen takes g6 that
rook on c2 is a hero
it is and where's that king going king
queen g4
e6 looks really strong queen takes g6
probably not out of the question either
by like queen g4 more it's threatening
yeah so because you have queen e6 queen
takes f6 and then making a new queen and
all the pieces join the attack for mate
wouldn't be surprised if that was the
finish to this game
all right queen e6 taking up six exactly
as you said what
uh rook h7 ricky's oh there's queenie
one meet
we we queen b2 oh the d6 pawn is hanging
and now we're h7 wow that was brilliant
holy smokes that was brilliant by
artemyev
and now takes on d6 and queen v8 that
was an
unreal game that was absolutely sick
he gave up checked so his king could run
away
and then played rook h7 so he's not
getting mated yeah how did he see that
yeah that was i mean the time it take uh
it took for me to see that and register
it
i mean not only am i flagging but i've
also gotten myself mated in one
yeah for sure and i guess that's why
oh yeah wow just trying to make sense of
it as they're like halfway through the
next game
yeah we're still on that last chance
happens to chess players but we will
lock into this one
it looks like black is trying to
collapse the white's poncho over there
on the queen side
and he doesn't take on g3 an important
lesson in tension that bishop on g3
couldn't go anywhere so he
saved the turn then took on g3 and now
he's just trying to take over the a file
yeah and we see here the two bishops i
always have a preference for it but
don't underestimate the knights i mean
the and h6 is a great move to stop g5
yes and queen d3 trying to get into the
h7 score of g6 and
we're seeing a bit of repetition here
knight h4 okay
and i'm wondering yeah is black one for
e5 but e5 is with the f5 square so it's
a bit dangerous
wow f4 can middle and i i don't know
if f4 was necessary there everything
just falls apart now
and and look at ryan's face he like kind
of slapped his head he's like no this
isn't going well
it's not how you play it no it's not
seven
look at those pawns rocker g5 three
connected pass pawns with the bishop
pair
gotta convert this just take it king e6
take that
next pawn and then c5 is about to fall
so just resigns
and eighteen and a half minutes left so
we still have two more games the very
least before we get to
the half time the break and for ronic i
think that break
is necessary it feels like he's starting
to lose the threat a bit
and maybe i'm just saying that because
the score but are timid for that
beautiful checkmating attack
and then just won that last game by
breaking open the center and winning
some pawns
agree and just as quick as that happened
he can bounce back but he will need some
sort of momentum some sort of energy
shift
in the other direction because right now
it does feel like
as we've talked about that phenomenon of
the stronger player
kind of waking up and bullet and
starting to to get in a rhythm
although it looks like black just stole
a pawn in the center and i'm not sure
about white's king
but now i see the eval bar going up for
artemia this is a
wild position neither side knows who's
really better but watch out for
something like knight f6
check and like bishop of h6 and queen g3
some sort of order
that's scary yeah yeah definitely
there's some queen g3 knight f6 stuff to
look out for here knight before queen
a3 oh my god you take pawn takes a3 and
now both your minor pieces are under
attack
but what do you do oh if cb a b and the
a file opening up is bad for white so he
just leaves the bishop there
oh my god and he says please take me
that's just a round of applause for me
this has been a phenomenal showing
by round no rook d4 because the brooklyn
f1 is hanging
that was unbelievable again look at the
triple stackers
on the scene the irish pawns queen a6
and i'm not even sure if i like black's
position
well the knight on a6 is doing the
lion's share of the work you're
protecting c7 and c5
and artillery's up on the clock by a
couple seconds that could be the
difference maker knight d3 huge that's
great anchoring with c4 that was really
well done
and there's like a mating attack on oh
and d1 hanging rook takes b2 rook d2
check but
wait a second it's silly and that easy
because your pawns aren't very good on
the queen side this is probably the
worst
four pawn advantage you could have in
chess still amazing but
definitely not the best as far as four
extra ponds go no
and four has become three and round
doing a great job throwing those
occasional checks
just causing white some problems here on
the clock and also winning on the board
nice brook b3 i sounds like crazy to say
nice after missing a free rook but
that was a pre move and it was a check
and it was on a defended square so
that's that's the best kind of pre-move
to do
yeah that was a very wise play
considering the situation it just helps
optimize his winning chances he felt and
now
we see an even score and we have a karo
khan
and this queen a5 check take on f5 so
you didn't have to double his pawns but
he spent time doing it bringing his
queen out
right yeah this is just a solid solid
position queen
b5 not looking to give up the b7 pawn
and
also not probably not that interested in
taking i think neither side wants to
trade the queens here technically and he
only takes after the rook left the a
file because i was giving a semi-open a
file to white
now black has control of the open file
so very nicely done by both players
they're
artemium i think he has a slight edge
and this is where i feel like
the uh skill like classical chess and
experience
pays off there's openings those little
things there but what i'm impressed
about by ronald r66 by the way no longer
but rookie 66 was an idea um is that
radic responds
instantly even if he doesn't know things
for certain he just goes
and that's impressive that's what you
need in bull you need that go mentality
f6 played
i like it g4 and g5 you can't stop that
with h6 this is gonna be really powerful
for the white pieces although there's
some kind of knight d3 situation
happening so he does take enough to
check
he can't play knight knight d3 that's
just
like yeah you got to keep the pieces on
and b4 good move trying to undermine the
defense of that knight there b63 is
possible with 96 checking
six so this is now turning in our
tamiya's favor
it is yeah and just slipping away here
as rook c5 knight takes c3 there's rook
c3
check very important now knight d3 is a
threat so you want to watch out for that
wait
93 rook c3 nicely done just
perfect tactical and rookie one take
with check and rook d1
yeah there's an unbelievable oh great
move though king of four because rook d3
is rook c5 so he's hanging in there
he is okay should be a win i think he's
just bring the king over
rick d5 check nice waited for it dragged
the king the fifth rank and that's game
and our tamiya wins that one so it is
going to be break i think this game's
gonna be canceled there it is
yeah wow this has been a really back and
forth affair oman
i feel like artemyev you know he has all
he can handle right now rhinocerony
is not a step behind i think it's
actually a very even match thus far
yeah it definitely feels like um ronak
was out of the gate flying you mentioned
up and down
uh definitely felt like a great start
for ronald sadwani artemyev seems to be
finding his footing which is a scary
thought when
a 3200 bullet player gets comfortable
that's that's what you want to watch out
for however
ronic as you mentioned he has a lot of
things in his skill set like
being able to just make that immediate
move not over analyze the position that
we haven't seen
either player just getting crushed on
time or anything like that so
i felt like the match has been very
close thus far we've just been treated
to some
intense bullet this morning robert we
have and we'll see
if the players can keep it going we're
gonna take a quick break and
return it'll be the second half of the
second wild card match in the bullet
chess championship presented by
sig
so
[Music]
and as we return we remind everybody of
the bracket of the players taking part
in this wonderful bullet chess
championship presented by sig
you see that we're in the match on the
bottom left vladislav artemyev takes on
roundok sedwani we already saw arjun
arigaisi
beat levon aronian so it's the super gms
taking on the
indian teenagers in the opening round
amman
even after this even after the second
half of this match we'll still have two
great matches ahead
yeah that's the most exciting part of
today the wild card days we get to
see these these players who have
qualified uh from the
uh the matches that we commentated last
week and we get to see them facing off
against one another
ultimately for a spot in the you know
semis and finals of this tournament
indeed where the opposition only gets
tougher we have four players waiting in
the next round takara nakamura ali raza
faruja
andrew tang and dania naraditsky it's
the bullet specialist the who's who
the upper echelon of the bullet sphere
so we're excited for that but i'm just
excited for the next half of this match
to go because it's four and a half three
and a half
in artemis favor a one point lead the
minimum margin you need to win the match
but ronald sidwan is not going to be
deterred and here he goes with the black
pieces
yeah and this this match of a little bit
of a shift here bishop on g5
instead of the bishop f4 that we have
been seeing and c4 immediately
uh saying look queen b6 you want to take
my pawn i don't care go for it this is
bullet chest
and i think it's a good decision by our
tim you have to switch it up you don't
want to get your opponent in a comfort
zone now it's just a new position look
at the double pawns the king on e8
not going to be a truly safe king for
black
yeah and rook g8 well if you thought he
might be castling king's side
not happening rook g8 and michael
queenside castling and bishop h3
already thrown out um some pressure on
the kings side early
and look at that just keen h1 getting
out of the pin bishop f3 giving up the
h2 pawn and he takes it
because of the g3 you're taking on g3
ripping that king open
and that's a decision i mean obviously
he's going to take it
both of these guys are happy to be in
this position right now i'm not sure
which side i prefer
i feel like i prefer white because i
don't see the checkmate
but then again i'm going to regret that
as soon as i say it
and it's also about the time so if you
can keep the time
level that's that's all you need with
the the white pieces
as black sometimes you don't need your
attack to work you just need to be up on
time
and look at this the defense turned into
offense at the snap of your fingers
because that king of b8 is no safer
than the king of g1 the king of g1
actually has a bunch of pieces defending
it but where is the mate you would love
to just remove the d5 pawn
not so easy in fact d4 was captured
right
and i'm not actually sure where the me
is
allowing rookie seven seems bad but
there was king d6
quintix d8 next up that that's free rook
okay so knight f3 it's still not over
it's not oh it's an exchange now
from a piece to an extreme oh sorry wait
what
i'm losing track of the pieces it was a
piece that it would
it was a piece and then a free rook so
now anyway
we're here now it's we got these three
pawns on the king side
and a3 is super important as white you
got to protect the heck
out of your remaining pawns you're going
to need them to win this game oh well
that's the one seemed to be the wrong
move order because now
it's just going to try to kick the king
out slowly shuffle back and forth
how do he see that so far in advance
yeah it's it's really impressive here
oh don't push that pawn so much it's
going to be a draw i think this will be
a draw
yeah only black could win this game but
obviously our tamiya
is way too quick getting over there yeah
artemia started pushing his apon
away from his own king he needed to have
the king's support and he
would have been in a winning position
but instead we see a draw good hold by
run up there
and now it's remains a one-point match
artemis takes the black pieces
and it's a calm opening from white no
central tension just yet e4 is what i
expect
yeah we need to see e4 from white
otherwise black might think about e5 and
e4
himself winning a piece and we see some
trades here
isolated pawn for black i tend to feel
like it's easier to play against the
isolated pawn
in bullet but there's too much activity
for black right now the pin on the
knight and f3
oh and i was about to say c3 if you take
this knight
all of a sudden yeah 96 is a great
response they're
keeping the the bishop under attack
bishop takes h6
hanging pieces lesson number one when
you know you can take your opponent's
piece but you're just hanging maybe you
could take something else in between
and that's there goes the h-bomb yep a
nice desperado tactic there
and basically he's just got a normal
position up a piece he's even got the
the bishop pair to boot there's bishop
takes e4 or knight takes e4 that both
seem to work here
yeah it is you're absolutely right
normal position but the h-bomb was gone
and now it's two extra pawns
two bishops for white yeah are tamiya's
in trouble
but he should try to play this out
there's the f2 pawn maybe you'll lose
sight of that rook to d8 comes and
maybe there's some tactics that black
has
available to him 100 percent and uh
position like this though if you're on a
you gotta you gotta chalk this up to a
game that you need to convert
if you want a chance in this match
positions like this you can't go
uh without grabbing a full point and
speaking of grabbing he just went took
that pawn on b7 i wasn't even looking in
that direction i was like oh how do i
get my rook out he says no that's
pawn make it a number three and black
has no attack the f2 g3 is
very stable and he's gonna try our
tamiya but he's also down on time
he is h5 g5 is going to be the answer
king h7 probably
tricky moving bullet but really nicely
answered by rana
and the only threat was queen h2 which
was actually mate so he plays rook to h1
which is also good for the attack
and don't blunder f2 and you win this
game for white
rookie seven such a quick move dealing
with queen g6 so effortlessly
and actually i think bishop takes f2 was
an idea there when the queen was all the
way on the queen side but it doesn't
matter
round up too fast way ahead in the clock
and now he's winning the game
yeah that was that was a really really
good game he needs that to bounce back
in this match and are we tied up
five all we're tied five points a piece
and right now back to the b3 you know
everyone's favorite nimzo
larsen opening and d4 gotta play that
and just try to open up the center yeah
jefferson f3 check
knight c3 here probably yes and you just
follow up with like you know eventual h3
f4
queen d2 and he's going to be long
castling so this should be a very fun
match
and 94 doesn't threaten anything we try
to get to the f6 square so
maybe it threatens more than i gave a
credit for because if the knight moves
knight f6 check
oh gosh oh he takes it i thought for
sure he was gonna get the bishop on f6
and just go for
that kind of
that's a nice movie oh he's baiting him
into it yeah that was a good one
good spot i think when i was looking for
soft points and black's
defense and the f6 square was like oh
maybe i can get that and yeah rook h7 is
coming now without giving up a rook
and then okay yeah he's had enough of
that fancy stuff robert he says look let
me protect the rook and throw it in
there but now black is losing at least a
piece because that's 96 blocking you
just take
the knight and the rook and some mortar
now you lose a full row
yeah this knight c3 uh actually there
isn't it's checkmate in one
so yeah i can't even try that knight
can't move it's mate
round throws in the towel on that game
and artemiev
look at him stone cold he hasn't not
emoted
a single time yeah i that's the thing
about
our tamiya evan thing about good bullet
players i think
do you see that though i don't know why
but all of a sudden he kind of grimaced
so
it's the opening must be did he miss
some kind of queen a5 check or something
like he he really was not happy with
what yeah queen a5 bishop b4 maybe could
have been thrown in there but
i i don't think it was anything too too
bad
yeah but that's that super gm mentality
where you make
even the slightest mistake and you're
upset about it but now he's up in
exchange and ronic
i don't think has enough compensation in
fact he doesn't have any compensation at
all
no this is this is really tough because
this is gonna take
some time off the clock and could still
result in in a loss but obviously you
you know you do play this one on
oh i was going to ask you at what point
do you start just resigning because
you're down one point you're likely
about to be down two
if you are unable to save this game
which okay
wait a second d1 he's playing it like
this is all
intentional yeah but b1 is a big move
next
ever b1 looks great and a queen a7
hitting g1 and
a2 between 7 would be nice
just like i'm not convinced by this at
all not even the slightest
okay an f1 mate mate oh
right when he uh basically got out of
the woods there i was gonna say because
you have the three connected pass bonds
over there sure they're not mobile but
at the same time i i didn't see how
black was executing a checkmate other
than just threatening meeting one
and did you see running kind of his hand
gesture there like he's uh whatever it's
a throwaway
i think he kind of had resigned as soon
as he lost the exchange and that happens
to us in chess where
even when we get chances and we're
playing well we're so focused
on that memory of how could i just lose
that piece like that so
unfortunately for him he was not able to
rebound but the e3 pawn
is now his so black is up a pawn and
that's good news for round he needs to
win his games
yeah and we saw artemia do something
there that
um is really important in bullet he
played f3 knowingly giving up that e3
pawn he didn't want to deal with an
attack from raunak he says hey
i'll beat down a pawn just to have
places for my pieces to go and make
easier quicker moves
and it's justified yet he is down upon
he is worse in this position but look at
this h4
and black is the one with the less safe
king right now
maybe you can play on both sides
all right so how to make progress for
either side that's what i'm trying to
figure out is why can i play b5 at some
point to kick the knight well the knight
goes to e7 and back around to the
the king side does it without b5 right
and queen back to g4
knight d5 uh coming up soon
okay goes to g6 i like your 95 move
though
yeah is g5 just hanging here yeah
oh it's getting worse wait knight's
pinned rook's under attack
oh oh nitric check oh what a nice move
the knife fork and that wasn't to win
material that was to save material
because it looked like he was about to
lose something there oh oh
yes it's not the fisher bishop that
bishop goes around and
all right this is just bishop d6 win
wrong pawn
a pawn's the wrong square so if for
black you can some trade-offs in pieces
especially the king side pawns you have
a better chance but you're losing f4
directly it seems
king d5 just look at the knights getting
dominated by this bishop
so if you trade one pawn and then take
the you know you take the b and c pawns
off you're going to make a draw
mm-hmm you know
a5 he's getting rid of the apon he's too
smart
bravo that's a really classy stuff there
and just don't go c6
yep he knows better really nicely that
was a gorgeous end game
it was and that looks like it is
probably the match
actually i shouldn't say that because as
long as you start the third game start
the game yeah so there is enough time
but
ronic needs to win this game i take it
back it's not over yet but he absolutely
must win the game and he's going for
this
magnus carlson type of fianchetto on the
queen side sicilian newcastle queen side
and he's gonna push his pawns forward
oh yeah d5 a very quick reaction in the
center of the board
normally that's a very good sign if
you're black to get to play that move
and i think he could have taken on d5
with his knight because the bishop on g7
was left undefended there so
still opportunity miss because a lot of
pieces are getting traded and if i had
to pick a game where ronak was going to
win this wouldn't be
one of the first ones that comes to mind
no now the queens are getting traded
black is the better pawn structure white
is the head on time though so roundik
needs to
play quickly and look at this kingston
e3 all of these moves make sense
he needs to maintain the lead on the
clock but they're 30
plus seconds left for our tim we have
too much time it it does seem like too
much time
he'll be happy to trade trade trade here
and then get the rook to d2 now yeah oh
this is
you're well you're definitely not
winning this unless it's on the clock so
you may as well keep
trying to play quickly and b4 b6 would
be
a terrible end to that game yeah self
mate
and well rook d4 looks good king can
come to d6 if you need oh i like that
move though the b6 pawn now veronica has
some chances rook a3 or rook b1 okay
protects the pawn okay took that one
i feel like white should be better here
despite being a pawn down yeah i
i get that feeling as well that the the
pawns should sort of advance like
oh and he's taking the h pawn five
take an h5 i think white's winning brook
h1 back and then push your c and b
bonds yep c7
king b7 yeah he's got this oh rook a1
nice move and the queen and the b pawn
oh well that makes it easier but artemis
i i think maybe should have played it
out
yes he not not only should have played
it out
but he should have played rook takes c8
regardless so right there's a few
things that i mean artemiev could maybe
put this match away if you just
extended the game a little longer right
because this game started with about
220 on the clock 215 which gives ronick
enough time if he's able to win this
game
but yeah that's a big either must win
another must-win situation
all right now g7 is hanging but g2 is
hanging in response so f3 played we've
seen
our team play that move many times in
this match and he's just trying to play
as solidly as possible but he's down
six seconds yeah and sadwani knows
exactly what his win conditions are here
yes he needs to play quick and he see
he's trading off the pieces a lot of
people say
you need to win why would you trade
pieces because he's playing quickly
he knows that he can win this game on
the clock not just on the board
mm-hmm and it's nothing wrong with his
position either he's got the two bishops
here
um he's going to try to keep them bishop
c8 yep
he could have taken on c4 before but
he's just making quick moves he's like
barely
thinking in depth he's just making moves
based on feel
and i really like the move g4 just in
terms of the match
right here from artemia if you can play
a4 c4
lock things up right and b5 you just
leave the pawn so you do not want to see
that bishop get into the game and
he plays that four is artemia playing
for a win yeah
i mean i get the feeling that uh artemia
doesn't really care about the situation
he's too objective
and while he can play bishop d6 and
trade off the
dark square bishops 97 97 87
yeah 97 is just sitting there and that
is the match
that feels like it because there's no
way that ronnie can win
especially after the trade there no way
to win the the game and
in fact you're just going to lose it
there we go that should be i think
they'll they'll still have time for one
more game but
that should not impact the outcome of
this match
yes and well artemiev he is making his
way
through he it seems to be a very worthy
competitor
i said beforehand that i thought that he
could match up against any player in the
field no matter if it's hikar nakamura
who he would face in the next round but
artemia he he had moments where he
struggled so we'll
it's going to be interesting to see what
he needs to fix in order to take down
a heavyweight like ferruja absolutely
and that that is an exciting match
up to to look forward to as we see
g5 from our tamiya of the the full send
on the
on the king side and i mean hey when
someone attacks you robert
obviously you're a little scared when
someone attacks you and it's artemia i'm
a little more scared than usual
yeah and artemia after beating materius
bartel
in the game of the year he's like let me
just send that g-pawn down and go
checkmate my opponents that was really
fun the first time
everyone seemed to love it a godmotor
made a video about it so
let's try it again yeah give it another
go
bishop's hanging on h3 by the way yeah
that queen on b3 such a sneaky piece
going for the attack and the defense
across the third rank
he's gonna stack on g2 yeah just you had
a sense that it was coming
yeah i mean he's already got the the
match uh secured so
may as well have just a little bit of
fun mm-hmm
oh queen g8 was possible there a 96
check that's a nice tactic
that's a really nice tactic and here in
knight of 492 okay you get
what two minor pieces for rook if you're
white
yeah it's very reasonable it should be
good for rounduk in this final game
okay i like avoiding the exchange there
um the three pieces i think you can
utilize a lot better
than you know the knight and rook for
black yeah they're awkward pieces and
now with
pawns uh pass pawn for both sides the
past one for black not going anywhere
you can start playing your f pawn at
some point but i like that he's keeping
his pieces together for now before
deciding
to push the pawn yeah the thing about
this position is black can always go
like knight takes
f3 even if it's just like run the pawns
and pray
yeah and there it goes all the way to f6
the king comes up to help then i can go
back to e6 i guess to defend the f8
square what a
weird position what a weird position oh
okay you can't take on a four
knight f8 oh he trades
he could he could promote it night in
bishop
no time for other player though so who's
actually going to win this game both
sides of chances
should be winning but uh he's actually
black probably wins this game in
practice
a2 is not the the winning move
you know if this was like came down to
it robert crunch time i think black
plays king c3 and flags there but
the the match was already uh already
over right i didn't need any more
victories he has won this match
nine now six and a half vladive artemyev
moves on and
aman what a performance by artemia
because he lost
game one and then he stormed back
yeah and we've been seeing that time and
time again in the matches so far
we'll see if that continues in the
upcoming matches but the higher rated
or at least the person that we have as
probably the favor the more experienced
bullet player
tends to take time to warm up but once
they get going robert they don't really
stop
no they're not but we must stop for now
we'll take a short break when we return
we'll bring vladislav alternative on
for a post-match interview you will not
want to miss his thoughts
[Music]
and robert and i are back joined by the
winner of the match you guys just saw
vladislav artemyev
and vladislav it seemed like at the
beginning of this match
it was a slow start for you as you you
lost a few games early on
and had to make a comeback did you feel
like you're a bit nervous or just
getting used to bullet at the beginning
uh yes i think that it was very
difficult much for me because my
opponent was a very quickly player
he is very young player so before the
match
i i wanted played
play more solid but i understand that
it's very difficult to
control without increment and
it's true that in first part of march
i have big problems and only
in the end of march i have
some advantage maybe and
i'm very happy that finally i won
yes because because i think if we
had one second increment it was more
stability
because it's more about
calculating variations
and vlasive i have a question for you
some of these especially younger players
they play
30-second do you play 30 second chess
ever
ah no never
i i like blitz usually
example three minutes plus
one or two seconds okay sometimes
i play title arena only
yeah one min yeah and well you know so
we have title events you've done very
well in the title tuesdays recently i
think you've won
three events in the last couple months
uh yes i was winner of a few
great events on chess com i think that
i have five victories in
title tuesday i i won two tournaments
in last year and in this year
probably three tournaments very
impressive stuff and
maybe that is a little bit more to what
you were talking about with the
increment that you have that plus one in
that tournament and
you've played in you know some speed
chess matches before where it's always
one minute plus one second so did you
feel in this match like you were kind of
racing against the clock as your
opponent as you mentioned was very quick
in this match
i feel that i was more nervous that
usually
because i i think
that my opponent was
more quickly than me but no not many
uh yes i wanted to have some control
and trying to play positionally
i usually and when i have black pieces
i choose g6 sometimes
bishop g7 and
oh okay i i think that i
[Music]
i i doing uh good work
and and it's a very interesting
experience
but if you want to have my opinion i
i will choose the increment well
i have a question for you vladislav
because you're moving on to face alireza
farouza
a player you know very well what do you
think about that matchup because he is
such a strong bullet player
uh yes i i think that
it will be very interesting much for
both
uh but still if
objectively aliera is a little favorite
maybe
because he had a good
practice in bullet i remember
how i watched his matches with
daniel nirajitsuki and it was
less than one minute it's very
very fantastic yeah yeah it's pretty
pretty amazing to watch what
the best bullet players in the world can
do with little time but
you yourself flat assad definitely among
them and we certainly
enjoyed watching the match today so
congratulations on the victory
and we'll certainly see a lot more of
you in the remainder of this tournament
and good luck against your next match
against perugia
uh thank you guys for your support it's
very
it's very uh pleasant for me thank you
of course vladislav very welcome have a
great night yes we will wait uh
tomorrow much absolutely and that was
vladislav artemy of everybody a
super grand master from russia one of
the kindest
players you could possibly meet always
great with the interviews and well
aman now that that one's in the books we
have probably a pretty
personal match up to you next as
minleigh
gm inlay here on twitch takes on
none other than chess bra eric hansen so
you know i'm going to ask it i know what
you're going to say but i'm going to ask
anyway
what do you think about this matchup
who's the favorite heavy
eric's heavy favorite easy win uh chess
bra all the way for life
um but no this is a replacement match
obviously i'm happy to see uh eric in
the competition
getting some uh some games in but he was
available as the last
second replacement that's that's just uh
you know the chess bra
lifestyle robert always available as a
last-second replacement
well he is ready for action he has a
very tough opponent
in international mastermind lee the only
i am in the field but a gm in all of our
hearts and just such a strong player
so we'll see if eric's able to take that
one and before we get
into that match we just want to give
another shout out to sig susquehanna
international group
for sponsoring this event and if you
want to use your gaming skills in your
career
sig is the leading global proprietary
trading firm that uses game theory and
decision science
to win in the financial markets to learn
more about sig
visit sig.com chess
amman we are two matches in that means
two
full matches to go it is eric hanson
your partner over there at chess bra and
he's taking on min who we know is a
superstar in his own right
i don't know who the favorite is i'm
going to give the slight
nod to eric i think that he has less
pressure on him
he just got invited even even though
he's going to play
so i'll give that to him yeah i think
you know all jokes aside it's definitely
um a very intense matchup between
two players where you sort of feel like
the ratings that they have coming into
this
aren't really gonna factor like if if
eric comes in rated
3200 and you know min lay comes in at 3
000 i think we both know that
they can play at you know the upper
echelon of bullet chest levels
and i don't think that's going to be a
factor at all we know both of these guys
are capable of 31 3200 ratings at all
times so
min lay definitely uh probably has a
little bit more practice
uh recently in bullet i don't think
eric's been playing as much bullet chess
but
when we saw him in the qualifiers eric
was the guy who missed out on
qualification by half a point
one point every single time so i felt
like he had
an unfortunate performance where he kept
missing the qualification robert but at
the end of the day that also shows
consistency
throughout yes and for the sake of full
disclosure dimitri on drinking had to
withdraw
from the event and at a moment's notice
there was a replacement needed
and that replacement is eric hanson so
it was a scramble
to find it but eric stepped up and we'll
see how he is and i see him on screen
we'll show him in a second
you know he looks a little sleepy i'm
going to be honest with you mom
well i mean this is the a.m after all
robert
the chess bras barely even know what
that stands for
well it stands for another match for us
because this is the
third match of four today in the wild
card round the winners move on to the
quarterfinals where they face
the four seated players hikaru nakamura
dania naraditsky andrew tang and alireza
ferruga
and well we're off i see that game one
is starting erica is the black pieces
that is a quick start and uh we are in
here ready to go and the players
actually do come into the match speaking
of ratings very similarly rated
and already with e5 i mean this is a
quick start here
yeah and look at this i mean he's a
system player in bullet chess and he
plays them extremely well
very solid approach from white's point
of view and the big question is is min
going to play with like c4 e4
well eric says you better think again
because your queen on a3 would have been
under attack
right and knight e6 already a5 happening
i feel like this is a fantastic start
for eric because you see the eval bar
trickling up there with eric's not even
up upon no but he goes bishop g7 instead
of
trying to take on before the rook and
eight was hanging he goes let's go after
the c3 pawn that's a new weakness once
you played b4 so eric
is also up 20 seconds on the clock not
going well for me in game one
no i mean look look at how long he's
been sitting in this position i almost
wondered if he nearly disconnected or
something because that was like a
15 second think in a one minute game uh
unacceptable and i think that's just
you know game one jitters and i was
saying i thought that mean would be more
nervous because
he's been getting ready for this match
yesterday all day today
and aaron's like wait max what are you
talking about i'm sleeping no no you're
waking up real fast here
and this is going to it should be a
victory for eric he's up
several pawns and he is well ahead on
the clock
so game one looking to go eric hanson's
way with the black pieces
yeah and i think it's a lot more about
the time sometimes the situation like
this
the conversion is not always perfect but
you glance over at your opponent's clock
and wait a minute i have double their
time
i just need to make moves that don't
hang pieces oh young peace
he just you are the ultimate jinx
he hung up bishop as soon as you said
that
i'll be over here just you finished off
this game foreign actually now it's like
closing in on a potentially drawn rook
end game
but the extra time that's going to be
the difference maker here but min is so
fast is he going to make up this time
deficit it
it would be truly impressive here four
seconds to 14 is
unless there's like a repetition there's
just no way
yeah and king of seven oh he's getting
one of the pawns it doesn't matter
though there's no time
it just doesn't matter yeah just take
the rook now and you actually might be
winning on the board there
yeah and i even like the decision not to
take the rook because you don't even
want to allow
the possibility of something trading and
simplifying so
conversion you can see the most upset
player with that result is eric hanson
yeah look at him he's i cannot believe
that just happened
he's trying to gather himself and this
is the donna nereditzky the second move
d5 from min
it seems like these players rub off on
each other playing so many blitz and
bullet games and the bishop on e4
looking nice for eric in the center the
there's a lot of tension there
going on bishop before check probably
castle kingside for men so yeah
i think it's a reasonable position thus
far it just uh
it's not going to be about this opening
stage i i think so and that's such an
interesting i'm going to queen v1
talking about double attack
oh gosh as soon as he castled b7 and h7
under attack
eric definitely has the better start of
these two players
that's clear yeah but you know actually
uh we haven't seen the person with the
better start end up doing well in these
matches so far
that's a very good point the slow
starters have been winning the matches
that starting d5 what's happening there
bishop takes a rookie one yeah it looks
like a rook d1
takes on d5 queen takes c4 trick oh very
nice
very nice spot there and i was going to
say queen takes d6 but then i realized
it's a pawn protection at night
so yeah i was going for a fancy tactic
that would have just blown under the
queen
well that's that's what fancy tactics
are there for to beat you in sometimes
rook e3 is heading over to g3 and watch
out because the attack
for white is actually going to be
crashing through it looks like open
files for black
but the black king is is weaker than
whites yeah there was rookie seven there
as well it said rook to h8 so
trying to get some counter play here
what
oh that's a blunder red one e6 rook f4
yeah there's a de6 work at ford ef7
he just moves the queen back yeah i was
i think you had to go for like the
rookie seven type of stuff there and
just admit the piece is gone but
what's happening here eric's up on time
but min has been playing fantastic this
game really good defense
yeah but i think the time here is such a
big factor i mean it's so fast
he's so fast oh my gosh wow yeah could
you do f4 the queen's trapped otherwise
and now eric's down on time yeah and
this is just lost
wow lost what a turnaround we'll see
though
that rook on h5 is a little awkward it's
true and now they both have six seconds
so they're both playing really quickly
and eric is super fast himself so f4
that rook strap
big move huge kv3 king of four move that
oh okay got some bishop
some serious moves coming in right now
the king of shelter on d6 and f6 he's
going for the mate
min saw that oh but time time time and
error gets it
these players are so expressive on cams
robert that when
i look over both of them are mad i don't
even know who won the game from the web
games
no it's really just a absolute bullet
brawl at this point both sides
we're down to the winning seconds and
the winning milliseconds really
impressive display from eric who was
actually down 11-8 at some point now
in this game here the queen and bishop
lined up in the long diagonal but white
is very solid
uh this knight on d5 not going anywhere
does protect the e7 pawn that's the good
news
the bad news is i'm always frustrated to
play these positions from both sides
and bishop h6 this is a very important
idea
knight f4 so it caused men to go for a
lot of these trades and usually once you
get to this type of position robert when
you play b5
simplify a pair of pieces you're really
happy as black yeah because white
doesn't have any
active play here and black is just
creating bad postures for what black is
one pawn island
from h7 to d6 and then white has these
scrambled pawns including isolated pawns
yeah bishop back to g7 so saying look
that bishop on g5 not doing anything and
then after queen h4 starts to reevaluate
with the attack coming
and i like rookie 3 rookie one knight g5
at some point just caused some threats
because that's what what scares people
in bullet chess yeah and if knight d5
there's knight g5 as well coming over to
the h7 pawn
okay and is there some kind of rook f3
rook takes up six probably too obvious
but he goes for rook e6 please take me
yeah that would be something there and
all right now we have trades so black is
feeling
safer in terms of the king but yeah
those trades
help eric out a lot in my opinion and
that's why he's playing rook c1
for a great move in my opinion yeah that
is a great move and the clock situation
is
better for white men up on the clock and
has an equally
unsafe king so i would say that based on
the time
but taking the position into account
anyone's game right now
i would take white three i would say
what taking white here with the time
um definitely be the smart choice are we
going to see g5 f4 yeah it has to happen
f okay it doesn't play f4 he could have
now he can't because rook g5 is saying
wow they're going to get annoying for
both though just
queen d5 would have however this is
starting to get easy to pre-move for
black i would say you can make premiums
around your king
right um and just keep the queen and
king in line
exactly exactly okay and min barely on
the clock now
there was a hang queen there but
obviously these guys are pre-moving
g4 tricky move but i'm not sure it's
good look how easily eric
the queen goes down yeah and now eric's
up a queen and pre-moving
and winning the game yeah so this is
what i was saying even though uh
mine was up on time there what eric was
able to do was pre-move the queen
right next to the king you're never
gonna get caught in a pre-move and what
was min
doing he was taking his queen he's
moving it three four squares away from
what
uh the last move every single turn so
tough to make uh
quick moves to keep up with your
opponent there it's just one of those
positions where the extra material makes
it too easy because there's not
much left you can't create threats so
min couldn't handle that in the time
trouble
and now we see a very solid approach
from in once again we exit a typical
pawn structure for him no matter which
color he has
with the pawns on b7 and c6 and f7 e6
and what just happened on the king side
i was going to say what what is that
that just looks bad
yeah i think men might be tilting he's
like i am down three nothing i need to
start winning games but
this is more likely to be a loss queen
f2 looks solid
yeah the knight comes in bishop f4
just to protect your knight okay rook d4
nice move in in fact
yep and min's doing well on the clock
here if he can sort of establish like a
knight on d5 maybe knight d6 from him
next
uh definitely still his chances knight
f5 and this is anyone's gaming bullet i
think yeah because the king safety
black's king is very safe tucked away
over there white's king is
wide open and in many rooms and d4 is
hanging so yeah if you took the pawn
he would have taken on d4 so now he took
this way and deforest stills a problem
so
he protects it i would love crazy enough
i would almost just take black
in bullet because you're making threats
every single move bishop on b5 doesn't
contribute
and black's position is so solid yeah
actually i agree with you here
and he trades rooks it's h3 that's what
three pawns it's too many the bishop is
doing nothing
that's the problem well now it's doing
something he said a month stop talking
trash about me
and f5 wow so queen b65
oh i don't know about e5 actually this
is double edged yeah i was saying queen
b6 with queen d8 queen h4 trying to make
a draw that way but
uh perhaps didn't work queen c4 bishop
d3
okay but four pawns now for the piece
yeah but i do like white's kings
knight g5 knight g5 is their
draw so they're almost there would've
been a mate if the king went to h7 so
that's before this one
is happening and now is running but
three seconds
3.8 seconds and he throws an f3
okay he's eric is catching all the most
king d2
no he doesn't have time he doesn't have
enough time and he had to draw with
queen a4 queen d1 he could have if he
had more time he could have just forced
and draw but no time
right right so strikes back
and he needs that he really needed that
we saw we almost said
um that this game was just him sort of
tilting it away with that sacrifice i'll
i'll
i'll say it again that sacrifice didn't
look good at the beginning but he kept
the speed up and his knights found
outposts that turned out to be exactly
the game that he needed for a chance at
this match
oh gosh and still anyone's match there's
20 minutes remaining here we get a break
when they're 15 minutes left
in it but right now with the white
pieces min trying to get a second
victory in a row
and he's the isolated pawn but his
bishop on h2 is
actually sneakily good piece knight c4
to d6
is on the horizon and i guess that's why
airport is not e4 just taking control of
the center
maybe queen d5 here he goes queen h4 is
also makes a lot of sense
um that you mentioned that isolated pawn
on d4 and not anymore as the f pawn
joins it but that f pawn on e3
suddenly means there's a lot more weak
squares around white's king but look at
that fine 97 with the fork of the rook
and the opponent b6 white is up a punk
queen f2
yeah i'm scared of moves like rook takes
d4 and generally like bishop coming to
d4 but it's not quite possible there
bishop c7 could write rook c7 as well
now white is up a clean
pawn yeah i have five though knight five
oh oh sorry i didn't even see the point
me neither i was like knight if i was
forced and then he takes the pawn there
so knight c4 only move okay rooks
oh yeah you can try to take this knight
here on c4 so what does
white do yeah there's no e4 bishop can
take the rook on c1 okay so
rook c8 and what's going on here just
take and
take on e3 yeah isn't oh and if rook see
there's nike one and roxy one's knight
g4
oh my goodness the rook is trapped here
rook is gone
what are the chances bishop f8 great
move as well take c3
rook a3 and bishop h6 rookie three mate
bishop h6 was
i think leading to a checkmate there
yeah oh look it's taking too many bonds
here
oh and he made himself as well and min
just laughs but i don't think it's a
laugh that he finds
yeah that's a that's a face
that's a laugh so i don't cry moment
and we've seen this opening before so
this is actually the exact same game
where he just sacrificed on g3
not sure that he's going to do that
again even though it worked out last
time
that's right it's not getting back to f1
it's a very solid setup
for both uh now e5 at some moment to try
to break open the position is what i
would go for
and min just brings next to d5 instead
and i feel like uh
eric has been sort of shuffling the
knights around like for five ten moves
and man has actually improved his
position significantly he has
and if you take on c5 bishop takes e5
black is the isolated pawn but the
bishop is staring at f2
and that's why eric put his knight on d4
yeah
e4 coming up i mean i think this is very
tricky bishop d4 obviously threatening
to win a piece right now
yeah so you probably just take the pawn
right bishop d4 and
cd maybe queen takes d4 but instead he
goes for the more active approach in
knight d6 to c4
very nice play by min right now and
sometimes you can even sack on e3 here
and go knight d4 at the end it's just
all over those dark squares and bullet
can be very tough to handle
and now c3 is weak in addition to f2 so
the knight comes back to e4 with a
double threat
and i was thinking maybe knight e3
instead of d4 say look i'm going to lose
the c pawn at some point at least let me
hit the d-pod at the same time
i thought it was 924 but knight on d4 so
it's okay
and now rook c3 works c5 for b6 will be
fighting
for b6 and right before no this is
winning for black on the spot
oh sorry for up over 65. my bad i
thought the rooks were being forced off
the board i spoke too soon
i still think this is winning because of
the time and the extra pawn
so i you might be able to save your
comment there robert
it might objectively be a win we need to
bring in our devretsky's in-game manual
and nicely done by eric though to make
sure he didn't have a two-on-none
but to make it a one-on-one outside the
board yeah no this is actually really
well played by eric i still think he's
the favorite to lose this game
but it is really well played uh by him
to try to earn
a different result f4 i'm not a big fan
of that move
yeah no time king of six and a three
yep and that yeah now it's now you're
you're hooped
yeah just check check play a2 and then
just like just
pre-move some random stuff is what i
would do for black yeah remember the
thing is you say pre-move random stuff i
would never pre-move because of rook
takes a3 as a trick when you have so
much more extra time
but the sentiment is there that you can
do whatever you want and just win on the
clock
right i always actually think just give
up the pawn and start trying to give
some checks but you're right that if you
are careless with your pre-moves then
your opponent pre-moves and
takes your pieces so yeah here this
looks like a very another solid
set up here for min and b5's committal
the dark squares and the queen side are
ones that white wants to take advantage
of
yeah and here i wonder if eric's going e
takes f6 and he does just to try to stay
on that e5 square
control some dark squares because as you
mentioned after the move b5
very committal right and that's why the
bishop's left on b3 if you take on b3
the knight
takes back and that jumps to c5 the
knights do better in these close types
of positions and i think i would move
the bishop from
f5 which i go f5 with the pawn that's
actually what he's doing
you're calling it and it's either going
to be f5 f4 or he's just going to leave
the pawn on f5 clamp down on the e4
square and improve his position in the
meantime bishop f6 king g7 and
go from there the problem for white is
you don't really control the pawn break
so b3 is a good start to
get some under your control but f4 for
black b4 at some point can be considered
and yeah it's such a locked up position
though maybe bishop e8 or c8 yeah
basically if black can trade these
knights off i think he should be very
happy with the position
and now now it's as close as it gets so
h4
yeah f4 h4 we were thinking of the same
thing just try to imbalance the
structure over there even just a little
bit and bullet though this is big
favorites white oh they blundered upon
so europe you're doing well with the
with jason people right now i i think i
owed
i think i owed eric one for the last one
that's true that's true
and bishop e7 was important because
knight takes g6 uh i feel like there's
some characters
at the moment oh my goodness
queen f3 yeah and quintes h5 queen f3 is
a very strong move king g7 do you still
go h5 or can you take that knight now
oh pawn takes that's just so nasty
yeah eric's just given that the nod of
approval like that was well calculated
yeah good job friend yeah because
there's queen h7 queen h6 check that was
the point
so good oh we can even show it i think
it's a half time so we can show the uh
that that final thing queen h7
i think queen h6 is the precise thing
and then
bishop to f5 yeah take this guy
ouch yep that's a good finish then
where did we end up is it 4-2 going into
the break is
i felt like eric had a really good first
half of this match
but right when the match felt like it
might slip away
minlae won some impressive games and
whenever min has won on the board it's
been an amazing calculation
and he's usually been up a lot of time
as we sell he's up 20 seconds in that
last game
just crushing yeah very impressive
showing there by men who bounced back
after a rough start but
eric looks to be in charge he's playing
very well under duress
even when he's down on time when they're
10 seconds per side
he's able to kind of outlast men in the
resulting time scramble so very
impressively sorry by eric
we are going to take a short break and
return we'll have more from this match
from the bullet chess championship
presented by sign
[Music]
i got into playing poker in college and
really liked it but
never considered i could make a career
out of it until jeffy ass came and gave
a talk at harvard
jeff explained that yes you can actually
use gaming skills for your career and
for something to do on a day-to-day
basis which was
exciting at the time i thought it was
really cool we can pretty much guarantee
you that we will give you the best
education you will be taught all that we
know
in a very professional manner by expert
teachers and
you're going to be mentored and i like
to think that there's no other place
where you can get as much mentorship as
you can
at susquehanna i think that the main
thing that everybody has in common
is a sense of competitiveness and
interest in in gaming and
strategy in general i would say you're
you're playing a game as a career
it's very satisfying to me that we've
been able to employ so many people
give them not just an opportunity to
make a lot of money but to be with the
smartest people in the world
and to have a lot of fun and make a lot
of friends and create a culture
of reason
and we return ready for the second half
of this match between
chess bra eric henson and gm min lee
also known as i
am mindly he is an international master
and title but by strength
he is one of the absolute best on the
server
amman four to two in eric's favor right
now do you think he has this under
control
well first of all it is four to three i
called out 4-2
as we were going into the break because
the game had just finished
and the score hadn't updated so it is
4-3 just to make sure everyone's on the
same page here mostly for myself and
uh that's what feels a little more
representative of how close
this match was and especially the win by
mid leg going into the break
yeah wow i can't believe uh i also
missed that and what's
four to three to clear clarify for
everybody especially ourselves
and right now eric has the white pieces
he is trying to
you know make things happen here and
this doesn't look like what he wants
it's a pawn on d3
and that's going to sit there because
the light square bishop yeah bishop on
g6
hitting the pawn i'm even thinking like
how do you even maneuver around
to trade for that pawn and i can't see a
way to do it
no that pawn is going to stay put and
well i guess you can play bishop e3 and
the pawn can't make any real progress
so eric is thinking i don't know what he
was thinking about maybe throwing
queenie
check in first but he said just uh
brings the bishop back
and now do you like the outside pass
palm potential for white because that
pawn is blockaded very firmly on d3
i do i i do like even here b4 b5 a4
i can see this working as you can see
the computer eval has that around even
but i just feel like
white's blockade is so sturdy well
trying to take away the bucket and walks
into this pin here
queen f3 spotted by eric very quickly
and now he is up a piece
yeah and you can take on c4 here i bet
and
i mean even though the bishop's attacked
dark squares right the bishop on g6
cannot participate just play queen e3
and push pawns now
yeah the knight can just jump into the
action it's not doing anything on c3
that's
necessary there and here's the d7 queen
b6 and yeah that's a resignation eric
hanson wins so he's up five to three now
scores clarify and both these players
have played so many bullet games so even
though eric has the lead
you can't count out of the amount i mean
a min in particular i think he's played
just
20 000 games yeah some incredible number
just think of doing something 20 000
times in your life you'll probably be
pretty damn good at it robert
wow 20 024 bullet games and maybe that
doesn't include
these games that we've just seen but
either way over 20 000
games of bullet chess and right now with
the white pieces he's showing his might
in this format because the knight on d6
is very powerful the f7 pawn is a
weakness rook comes to e1 you can't put
a rocket e8 because that knight and d6
yeah it looks very promising for min
here it looks promising but knight d5
get that guy on d5 asap block the bishop
on b3 from hitting f7
and this is actually probably gonna be
more manageable for eric than you might
expect
i'm looking at knight g6 to go knight e7
because the knight and d5 is pinned but
that f4 threat was so powerful trapping
the bishop on g3
so i was going to say maybe rook b8 just
to you know finally move that light
square bishop
but after this bishop f5 i feel like
eric's totally out of the woods
yeah he is and his position is starting
to look good but be careful
along the e file that's the one thing
maybe i'll give up a pawn somewhere but
if my rook can land on e7
now we're talking yeah and g3 is you got
g4 as an idea although it does give the
f4 square so you have to be careful and
eric walks into a fork
it's funny he played king h8 almost
trying to avoid a fork he just handed
one over to his opponent
yeah looking up quickly min swung the
rope to b8 wins the b7 point for k7
taking on a
don't take them a5 yet yeah he's going
to take on a5 and he's just stealing
all the pieces yeah and eric's just uh
basically probably going to resign here
because he's going to have to exchange
pieces and he plays it on but what we
noticed is that when min is winning
games
i feel like he's winning it again like i
mentioned with an insane time edge
yeah and min is a monster and as you see
here he is
the highest rated i am on the site his
bullet rating
record is 33.57 peak
that is just absolutely absurd i
i thought they stopped counting at some
point robert i definitely can't count
that eye
well eric would like to stop the count
with 10 minutes to go because
he is up five to four right now and he
just played d5 so
maybe he's still enjoying himself he
wants to win this match obviously
but he just won a pawn and it just oh i
was gonna say take
f7 and d6 was um was a nice tactic there
obviously can't complain about an extra
pawn in the center of the board but
i think he had a lot better there well
extra pawn no more except
extra exchange so ct is captured he's
afraid
yeah bishop b5 he saw that very quickly
and that knight b5 at some point
this is just great technique by eric to
trade off some pieces
and the open c file means that it's not
really easy
for mine to set up any sort of blockade
of any sort
because the c pawn is always a target on
the open files
yes a 94 a bit of a strange move because
you almost trapped your own rook with
rook six f6
oh he had rook takes f6 there there
might have been some tactics there but i
think he was maybe getting concerned
with
his pieces uh all over the place there
he also is up on time
so that's the good news for eric he's
playing very quickly and
it is a knight sorry bishop rather in
one pawn for rook so that's actually
quite a deal of compensation
especially considering how strong the
knight is on d4 right now for black
so knight c2 there's queen e7 there so
he wasn't losing the exchange my
goodness
h4 hanging yeah just b6 protects c5 and
then
what do you do now so he takes this i
feel like this was good by by eric just
undermine that knight that knight
is so strong on that square and in rook
c4 knight f3
yeah h h4 played i think black still has
attacking potential but queen effect oh
yes
just perfect move knight e3 ninety-nine
three oh
knight d4 freaky both sides playing well
here i feel
queen takes f2 queen d4 yeah i play h3
first just like throw in that h3 move
make it right think i agree queen f3 has
an idea here you have to go he's got
seven seconds left
rook h5 and then take two oh that is
beautiful
and nicely done by i think by min to not
take the rook because he probably
pre-moved quincy's h5
yep he's being tricky here i don't know
about not taking the rook there though
he might regret that
that's main one made one queen oh
equini's a mate oh my gosh and he's not
gonna
oh he's gonna win anyway oh my goodness
oh
min is upset about that one i think what
he should have done was exactly what he
did
not take the rook immediately but you
have to take it eventually giving an
extra rook is too easy to pre-move in my
opinion
yes and the checkmate happened and wow
min was demonstrative there he is
not happy about that game because he
needed it
yeah and we see the time is now
something
that we're gonna have to pay attention
to and i wonder if the players are
starting to feel the exact same way as
soon as you get to seven and a half
minutes ticking down you can start to do
the math on how many bullet games you're
going to be able to play
for the rest of this match and they've
been going back and forth in this match
i mean look at this position white's
knights
are so strong bishop g3 threatening
knight takes g6 or something bad but
knight h5
how perfectly timed by er yeah just in
time and i
think yeah eric's going to take that and
be very happy with the resulting
position
yes because now the bishop pair for
black seems to be a safe position now
you can take any five and take twice
because you win a pawn
and there may be a sacrifice in g6 you
keep your eye on but doesn't seem to
work just yet
yeah yeah queen g7 seems to cover
everything bishop on d5 watching all the
squares the knights on c5 might want to
jump into
and if you take that i think b2 i
thought was just hanging although rook
b1 i'm seeing now
yeah rupee one nice find just to uh get
that knight of b6 and well eric trades
queens and takes upon a4 and b2 might
fall anyway just without queens in the
board
should be in nearly winning position
right now for black
yeah because you run that pawn to a2
it's supported by the bishop on d5
this looks like it should be working and
eric's ahead of the clock so he's
playing great bullet chess right now and
knight d4 would have broke b7 or b1
yeah that should be game over and then
just resigns six minutes and change
remaining so still time for min to mount
this comeback here
but he seems to be tilted yeah just a
little bit but when he when it seemed
like that was happening the last time he
came out with one of his best games so
he's going to need that right now as
with the time taking out six minutes
three game lead he's got to win this
game i feel
and he cast his queens i think he's just
smart because you don't want to face a
checkmating attack
and he plays h5 trying to open up the
position i think black is very solid
the typical min approach b7 c6 f7 e6
every single game and uh right now the
position's about to open up
but g7 is hanging but so is that f4 so
that's why he took
this way to pin well quote unquote pin
the bishop to
the the queen there and you mentioned
the f4 pawn hanging as well f5 and is it
gonna be g6
but that f5 pawn now for white that has
an eye kept on it and i love the move h4
and i love queen g3
yeah but hang on there's gonna be rook
gsa rick e7 as well
so rook h5 coming for black though and
then rook g5
mm-hmm this is really good stuff on e3
that's what you want exactly rook f3 and
knight e3
and erica thinks he's actually doing a
great job holding this position yeah
his pieces are so compact here
everything is protecting one another
and he's going to look at 4 knight g2
he's turning this around
you thought that the f-pawn was falling
it might be the h pawn all of a sudden
c3
is going to take his time if knight g2
f5 hangs you got to be careful
so i don't think either side can really
move here they're both stuck
they're both stuck but c4 c5
this is a hilarious locked position the
king goes to c3 now
okay yeah and the h4 pawn can be
captured and then rookie seven
rookie seven okay try to trade rooks
eric's probably gonna go for it with
rook h7 i would guess please no time
though
that might have been the smart decision
given the the match situation
yeah i was surprised by it but eric down
in nine seconds and min just trying to
flag him at this point because he's down
a bunch of pawns
knight g4 huge blender that's the
oh no you see man he jumped back in this
chair just yeah
he is not having this match right now
okay and eric's just pre-moving uh b5
will happen
he's going to get that pawn to c7 he's
got to stay in the dark squares that's a
really important move
being able to take that bishop there and
he should be able to
get a checkmate 1.6 seconds the night's
gonna be a bit annoying but
i think he's got it just in time and wow
you could just tell by his body language
he's just
he's i don't know what to do and eric is
bouncing now
he's got the head nod he's got the head
nod it seems to me
like uh that that was the match right
there needed that win
and then he needed to start the next
game asap at the moment three and a half
minutes taking down robert
shouldn't be enough yeah this is eric
hansen's match
and because he's winning this i think he
moves on to face andrew tang
in the quarterfinals that will be an
interesting matchup between two of the
most popular streamers uh on twitch
so it might be five wow nice tattoo
though by min
that's man talking about the match being
over i think eric's probably happy the
match is over when min's playing moves
like that
yeah here comes knight b6 i guess what's
going on right now two extra pawns for
white
yeah e4 and ip6
but aaron's doing his best to keep some
uh
aggressive possibilities for himself the
dark source king each other bishop h6
yep h6 rook h8 ideas oh you're losing
some material here
yeah getting rid of that knight but e5
oh
that's a dagger white's still better
because you're up two pawns to begin
with and so even though you drop an
exchange
that king on hm dawson oh talk about
every piece on the sixth rank
oh it's good that eric doesn't really
have to care about this game
because if this were a close match this
would be one of those
games that just makes you so angry yeah
this
this game is uh not a good
representation but it could also be said
that maybe that's why the game has kind
of gotten out of hand because eric knows
that
he's probably got this match secured
right
and there you just go c7 pre-move c8
and eric's is going to play it out
because i think so
smart yeah yeah you're just wasting the
remaining time so after this game here
there will only be this the next thing
will be the last one
yeah and when you're in these uh
situations you're not always paying
attention to the clock
right so you're not always knight f5 is
a nice cute mate there
[Music]
and eric not at all rattled because well
he's got this match and you're right the
players they don't always look
at the overall match clock but they have
a general sense but they might
he said i'm winning i might as well
waste time and
he did just that and now he's going to
take this match at worst by a two-game
margin
exactly maybe d6 here yeah that makes
the most sense
right give up the pawn you're gonna lose
it anyway so you might as well uh cause
some problems in black structure
and bishop c4 is a pin
that's a really annoying pin yes i can't
really do anything about that
the dark squares are also being uh fell
into weakness here
right i think oh d8 was hanging for free
yep d8 was very hanging which is why
after f3 he had to move the rook he
probably noticed it and he was like oh
man i guess i gotta move it but that was
a sweet tactic by eric there with a
sacrifice in the exchange to win the 95
min resigns so okay there might be
there'll be another game here and i
think this will be the last one
yeah and it's important to note that if
this match
restarted or happened again tomorrow
this result could be flipped like these
players are so
evenly matched for the most part in
bullet chess and you see that
we mentioned earlier min's highest
rating was 33.57
okay and he's at 3 100 right now so in a
given day you can go up 200 points go
down 200 points that's the nature
of the beast that is bullet chess yeah
and that's why the matches
has a the match right now has like a
four game deficit and
it's not really reflective of the
difference in scale it's just such a
streaky
uh format that as soon as you get on a
roll it often continues
and look at that mid midlay leads eric
166 to 138 in
all chess.com games so min actually has
the better record between the two
i don't know the distinction between
bullet and uh blitz
in that record but it shows that min is
every bit equal and maybe even just has
a slight advantage
yeah overall play but the only the only
score that matters is the one between
them
right here today in this match and uh
we do see a commanding victory in the
end on the scoreboard
however it felt like it was neck and
neck the entire way yeah i think eric
will find his final score to be
particularly nice
and on that note we will take a quick
break and we'll return we'll be joined
by eric henson the winner of this match
in the bullet chess championship
presented by sig
[Music]
and welcome back robert and myself
joined by
grandmaster eric hanson it's not too
often that you'll get more than one
chest bra on an official
chess.com broadcast eric not a lot of
people were expecting to see you here
today
when did you find out that you were
supposed to be playing chess
i think i found out a couple hours
before start time so like 9
9 30 a.m maybe
just just gotta just got danny sliding
into my dms
do you think that actually helped you
because this is a pretty stressful event
you're playing all these bullet games in
a row
tilt is easy to happen to you do you
think it actually helped that you didn't
have this
you know bogging your mind down for the
last day or so i
i think so i think that's like in
general that's healthier in chess
to not stress about these things so i
just came
in uh without expectations whereas maybe
if i
had won a qualifier i would have like
thought hey i'm a hot shot now i got
chances to go deep here i was like
i was just expecting to go in to just be
a last-minute replacement
and if any whatever happened happened i
i uh
it was relaxed it was a probably good
idea stream as well that
that would have just added more pressure
yeah yeah it's it's a
different experience when you're not
streaming and i think early on
uh in this bullet match robert and i saw
one of the games i think you're up
so much material so much time and you
ended up barely flagging min
and the webcam reactions from both
players it looked like everyone was
tilted so we couldn't even tell the
result
very emotional players that is that
something you had to keep in check for
the match today
definitely um fortunately i think i
controlled the tilt a little bit but
i was getting flashbacks i mean i just
like
you guys were commentating i choked four
straight qualifiers
and i was leading two of them by a full
point
and within half point of every qualifier
of a spot at least the in the knockout
so
i had lost so many it was the worst week
of bullet chest i've ever had
the final qualifier i lost three
straight games in a row to not qualify
at any point would have qualified
so i i'm glad i didn't have i just
didn't expect this
to occur and i was just coming in with
fresh legs because
i had way too much pressure on myself
last week and i really
well i really choked and deserved not to
qualify
as a result well you were that last
second replacement here
and you did take down somebody you
played many games against online and
you're actually going to play someone in
the next round daniel naradiski yes
who how many games would you guess you
played against donya
maybe 3 000. and a very accurate number
yeah like you seem like you know you
might know this off the top of your head
here and
what do you make of your chances against
him in this quarterfinal matchup
obviously donya is an absolute beast
yeah you've just proved against yourself
against min who is also a monster
i i think if i play like the type of
chess i play today that that was pretty
good but my speed
is not not okay so i'm gonna have to uh
play a little faster tomorrow
like to even be competitive dania is a
is a machine like hyper bullet bullet uh
you have to bring your like
best game and there were shaky games in
this match tons of shaky games from both
men and myself and i don't think there
would be that
margin of error allowed against a guy
like dania
yeah that's uh that's pretty much uh
what we expect when you're going up
against someone like daniel naredicki
but
we have a lot to look forward to and now
eric you actually
know you're going to be playing the next
match so we'll see if that uh
affects you i'm not potentiality no i
don't want to think about it i'm just
like i'll just show up here and and
business as usual and just
that's the way she goes well you know
you can have a nice celebration
stream on the chess broad channel i'm
sure everyone will be happy to see that
and
hey you know you didn't expect to be
here but now that you were here you
won a very good match and you got to
move on so there's
you're playing with house money that's
true i i agree
this is a free rule so i'm just gonna
have fun all right eric we appreciate
you stopping by and congrats again man
thanks guys keep up the good work
appreciate it cheers
that is chess bra eric hansen with the
victory over
midlay and well that was just the third
match of the day we have
one more nihal sarin takes on alexander
bortnick
the origin of bortnik strong was the
previous bullet chess championship
so we'll see if last time's finalists
can take down the
just prodigy from india nihal sarin
is one of the world's best players
especially in these
online formats so aman you know the deal
is the last match of the day who you got
yeah i would it wouldn't be the last
match of the day without one more of
these
uh bortnick first of all incredible
bullet player
one thing about nihal and i feel like
it's almost the same with most of the
indian players
so so strong but easy to underestimate
and we've seen in the qualifiers there's
a reason that so many indian players
qualified
amongst everyone they have nerves of
steel very young
very quick and obviously tremendous
chess players so i feel like
everything i just described is nihal
sarin he has this
this weird bullet style i actually
remember eric played a
match against nihal just a couple days
ago or something on stream and
you know neck and neck match so my
goodness he can compete
with the top top players i think
bortnick is a little bit more prone
to tilt and riskier moves and you know
maybe blunders here and there
nihal just seems like that consistent
machine the whole way
and in a short time control like this i
think that might give him the slight
edge
yeah nihal has been atop the leaderboard
for at various points on chess.com
the number one rated player in different
time patrols so he
is maybe not number one but close up
there maybe he was number one bullet i'm
not exactly possible check on that
but either way he has been one of the
top contenders in these time patrols and
against alexander portnik bortnick is a
beast and well we have the game underway
yeah didn't realize we were starting
that quick but the games are off here
and
we're joining just in time to catch a
familiar opening wouldn't you say robert
from the matches today oh yes
and it's a closed position because not a
single piece has been traded and it's
moved 18
and you don't see that every day and yet
this structure when is a player going to
take on d4
what's the deal here yeah i mean at this
point h6 probably being considered
and then the knight comes back maybe the
bishop goes back to e4 and black
snuck in the that that h-pawn there but
i think he's got different intentions
he's saying
that knight on g5 might even be trapped
soon
yeah and then he can't go anywhere so h6
right now that's played and
bishop d6 so he's gonna get the rook for
a couple pieces and maybe get a pawn in
addition to that rook
but this should be good for bortnick
yeah that should be fantastic the knight
on b3 has nowhere to go
sort of in part due to his own a pawn on
a5 and the
space for bortnick is is overwhelming so
that's why f3 had to be played
and that gives white some chances to go
after the black king right it's not like
the king is that safe especially with
the queen
lined up and a6 falling that's an
outside pass pawn yeah and i don't know
what the eval is according to the engine
here but i'm
very scared if i'm bortnik that i gave
up that a pawn and all of a sudden this
position is opening up
although where's this rook going because
you don't want to drop the e3 pawn and
bishop f6 very quickly can't go bishop
h4 because queen g6 is hanging so
i think that might have been a mistake
yeah definitely a mistake here and
there's no way this position is
salvageable just queen b7 game over
queen b7 played you don't even ask niels
arne twice he finds it trading queens
the a punk can't be stopped and
after knight takes c4 this rook takes g5
yeah
beautiful beautiful so there you go
we're getting started with
a game that i'm sure bortnick is going
to want back because we saw the position
earlier
he had the two pieces for the rook and
the better position but neil just said
look i might not have the best position
but you can always find the best moves
even in a tough position
yeah and boardnig actually has the
overall lead and their headset matches i
didn't expect that but
not too many games it's funny 50 games
not too many but that's
we just heard eric talk about 3 000
games against dania
and so i think you're qualified to say
that yeah it feels about right and look
at some of c5 just trying to
keep the extra pawn for black and now
the queen to go to d4 but now that you
take on bassan there's a d6
pawn problem queen can still go to d4 at
some point so yeah
i like white's initiative and well now
it's even material well you've got
reason to
robert as the initiative is not the only
thing he has he's even that material
and queen g5 has you know the threat of
knight h3
i wonder if it's gonna be an f though
yeah some kind of rookie one would be
nice but
you can't get there with the bishop one
before and black's back rank is also a
bit of an issue here
yeah maybe you can even throw in a
bishop c3 in a position like this
because
f6 and rook takes f6 is there wow bishop
d2 of bishop f1 your queen takes f4 i
guess and
try to go into this opposite color
bishop rook ending
yeah i'm trying to find a way to avoid
it but yeah i don't think there is which
is
great news for bortnick here even though
it's obscene color bishops you're up on
time
and you might just be winning anyways
and that's
yeah there's one of those moments where
you probably was b3 and you pre-moved
king g8
and now you lose a piece yeah i felt i
felt like he
didn't finish letting go of the king
from the previous move so he played king
f8 and almost just
still had his hand uh on the king there
and dropped it back on g8 by accident
and games like that where you're even
though you still have 18 seconds left
you know that you're in trouble when
your opponent has 10 seconds more than
you do so you're
just trying to pre-move as much as
possible to narrow that time gap
unfortunately didn't work and now we see
next game tied one to one
this is a queenless position where
honestly i like black's
chances in this one because there's no
weaknesses
yeah knight into d4 and i mean if you
take everything there there might even
just be a knight h5 at the end
uh that dark square bishop for white in
this position is sometimes worth a row
yes that's very true and well this
controller d
file is very nice for nihal right now so
what's black's plan going to be is to
move the rook
f8 to somewhere and then bring the king
over and try to go rook d8 i don't think
you can allow this pressure to exist for
so long
i'm waiting for e6 um after the move a6
it's a lot worse because then the d6
square is weak but e6 to prevent this
exact move right here
is what i was interested in because
treating all these pieces now white says
look i'm controlling the only open file
in the position
rookie said rook d6 and suddenly i feel
like nihal starring has all the
advantages
and there's like a bishop a7 move
possible at some point to cut the rook
off from the a6 pawn
so he's just trade oh and bishop d4
bishop b6
yeah and i'm wondering here
do you just go maybe king b2 yeah and
rook a7 that's
that's what i was thinking rook c6 rook
e8 leading to me
i feel like i would have wanted to give
up my c3 pawn on my a5 pawn because when
you take a6 you would have oh okay this
is just
winning now pin piece bishop b6 that's a
good try
but unfortunately it could be taken and
just don't play bishop e5
knee hell is too good to blunder that
yeah i was funny bishop
or bishop b6 that would have fallen
victim the same thing bishop e5 check
and
white would have lost the material
instead of black but this is just now
there's a conversion plenty of time for
neo
and the bishop can sneak its way from c5
to b4
although i don't think he's concerned
here
no rook d7 or king b5 okay he doesn't
go that way and said he just gets the
queen in plenty of time
just no stalemates yeah just take your
time with those moves and now you can
start to get the pre-moves in because
you know exactly where that king is
going
let's make by four so he wins 24 minutes
remaining
two games to one three games in and now
going with these like
modern setups that for knee halls i
wonder what his mind says going into the
match because artemia have said a
similar thing
yeah that the you know the plus the plus
one second
uh and the the g6 systems
maybe there's similar opinions there
well we know the g6 systems
that much is similar at least and i play
these positions many times online where
black tries to just
go over there on the queen side and
start attacking the white king
but it's actually hard to get that going
because you push b4
then your other pawns can't exactly help
out right and in position like this if
you have to play b3 and that gets taken
it looks terrible already
i never understand how you're supposed
to play this position with white
because the pawn back on f3 it's like
the only idea to attack play f4 but you
do that and look what happens that
bishop on g7 is a monster of this game
yeah it could not afford to allow that
knight to get trapped like it did to
have to go to a4 square you would need
it to retreat
but nihal perfect timing perfect
execution that bishop on g7
speaking of execution i think that king
on b1 is about to feel its wrath
bishop takes g4 here and i was going to
say maybe we're just going to see
you know just h5 take all my pawns try
to open something up now nihal says wait
let's trade those queens hang on hang on
you're doing the attacking now right and
so kicking that queen back you know a5
a4 b3 things like that
that's just the move you have to wince
that oh no
let's go oh my gosh
look at him he just grabs his head knee
haul he the knight on b3 was covering
the square
oh i'm i'm done i'm done jinxing well so
does it look like bournex suspended in
air like he's about to do the superman
like this angle makes it seem like you
know he
he's dangling in mid-air like he's well
with knight d4 that's a that's a piece
dangling in midair right in the center
of the board and
he's able to take that with zero gravity
yeah well
he is ready for liftoff here but
unfortunately for
uh for him i'm not fortunate for him
rather uh and not
fortunate for nihal it seems like
bortnick is flying away with this one
that really looks like the the blood is
rushing to his head he's got some
friends holding him upside down
he's looking down at the screen yeah oh
knight d2
wait but he don't have something with
check and king f8 you can take on his
takes
yeah no sorry but the king was in check
before so yeah
so it's just uh catching up here um
we're so focused on how he
how he's flying over there that the
pieces are also flying so right now
what's happening here white has
a rook and one pawn for 200 pieces
so seems okay for white definitely does
rook d6 and then knight e4 rook d7 keep
the keep the rook active in there
and that bishop on a4 is a little
concerning
and that's why it brings it back in the
game and defends not on f7 also covers
d5 you're playing on c4
and maybe black will play a5 a4 at some
point too
oh king of fade okay and now bishop
zero's b3
bishop two and a b3 b3 there's knight
take c3
yeah and b4 but 92 and if you take 92
you take what check and the bishop
results oh my goodness
what a move knight d2 he missed it
that was a key moment there and now
we'll see bortnick he's lower on time
but he's got everything defended
yes but look at this knight a6 movie i
think neil's going to move
around bring his king to g3 to hr watch
out for knight force though i play
knight f6
yep okay he covered the e4 square
very important i would not have taken
that bishop
oh but hang on he was winning that pawn
by force that's impressive
but it makes black's life easier in
terms of the moves that can be played
yeah when you can't lose if you take the
pawn you can't leave there you go
there you go and those are some hanging
knights there
oh don't make a move it's a draw oh oh
my goodness
oh god bortnick all right now we can
tell he's seated
he just grabbed his head like yeah and
he he that was the that was the look of
like
oh i guess that's just the kind of match
we're going to have let's go
this is a fun one indeed even score
feels about right
and let's see what's going on here it's
a potential attack for what the queen
came out mate
is there gonna be some queen h3 queen g3
oh watch out for knight g6 from knight
666 so you take on e5
and then knight c5 okay all this is
making sense
the knight on c7 is a bit of a strange
piece though it doesn't have anywhere
useful to go
and if knight b5 you almost just go
knight e2 say look your knight on
c7 or b5 or e8 it's going nowhere the
rest of the game
yeah so it puts an e8 middle f6 or f5
and try to get the knight out via f6
okay we see uh this is what castling
looks like in 2021 king f1 king g1 rook
h4 rook g4
a very normal state of affairs and now i
think f5 is is needed you need space
repeat you can can't leave yourself
just strangled and there he goes knight
takes f6 we see some trades
do you think what the pawn takes well
isn't there bishop obviously
oh my gosh the same blender yep and
bourne
his eyes got so wide there just work f7
and you have a piece yeah and it's
sometimes when things just are not going
your way you give that shrug like i mean
what am i supposed to do the world's
against me here i'm blundering
everything
yeah and he resigns and 18 18 minutes i
feel like we're near the end of this
match because
so much has already happened yeah and
yet we're just really getting started
yeah this is this is gonna be a fun one
uh you know it's the last
match of the day for us here uh we've
seen this opening before and i
thought that it could have worked out
better for bortnick than it did in the
game
are we gonna see the same position no he
takes the bishop this time instead of
the knight
and then he puts his bishop on e6
covering the d5 square and he plays
b5 you take bishop c4 what um
uh i think he was thinking rook b8 after
knight takes b5 he's like oh i have it
covered by the bishop on f4
didn't realize bishop c4 was the sneaky
intention yeah and he gets away with it
so nihal and now down in exchange
he definitely has some life left in this
position because of black's bad pawns on
the
queen side like if you can trade off
some minor pieces leave yourself with
that bishop on e3
you have some chances but i like the way
borton explains there's rook to b7
oh yeah oh i was gonna say there's 3d5
coming yeah a greedy guy there
okay stopping e5 now
all right just is that knight trapped in
c6 yeah i was going to say
94 it can be taken nice move rook d6
say bye to the knight yep i don't see
any way to save it here what a game that
was a that was a good good game from
bortnick there and i think he's even
this match
once again robert yeah and nihal's
missing certain tactics well both
players are
in the previous game it seemed that
bortnick blundered
a piece and then in other games neha
blender piece so both sides
have seen a bit shaky thus far
okay knight d4 is a typical french play
against that bishop on b7
it's locked behind his pawn on d5 and
now
i'm just gonna say i wonder if yeah even
just like f5 or something was was
playable here
taking that pawn on b4 results in knight
d3
check winning rook so bishop b5 look at
this i was talking about that bad french
bishop
now the bishop is being traded off
there's b3 ideas for black
there it is i think that black is just
crushing right now
yeah you almost got to go king b1 king
a1 or something
okay king's out on e3 so f6 makes
perfect sense let's blast that king open
and this might be the quickest you know
promotion that you've ever seen
rook f4 oh queen g5 check workout f8
mate coming your way
queen g5 now queen takes a check rook f8
check interpose
with check and if queen takes e6 brook
f7
but he didn't want to go into those
complications there's got to be rook
takes
f rook f3 rook f2 queen g5 queen
okay still fancy fancy queen f3 and g5
mate with a pawn oh my goodness what a
game
yeah in chess bingo that would have been
a nice one there check me with the pawn
down two rooks yeah that was that was a
clean finish and it was right
off the back of a tremendous game by
bortnik so that's exactly the momentum
that you need
to you know to combat that and this will
be the final game before the break and i
wonder who's happier about that nihal
you know seizing the momentum with that
win but every time nihal wins it feels
like bortnick wins the next one
yeah yeah talk about a close match this
is truly
players trading wins back and forth
and here we see pawn up to a5 trying to
chisel at black's queenside pawn
structure and that comes to c5 i would
take
play for knight c4 in the very near
future yeah knight c4 now a bishop a6 of
course take that pawn makes sense
you know i've sort of named that my head
is the roberto molina because the i am
not gm speedster championship he took
that pawn several times so
in my head that's the roberto knight d4
there you go that's
talk about a solid square this c takes
d4 and that bishop on h2
it's actually going to be well placed
here and black needs to try for some
kind of f4 i guess because you're just
going to be ground down
and bortnick is ranked number nine on
the bullet leader board so
he's clearly uh a bullet
beast and all players have talked about
him before
so he's just really really strong with
the finalists in the previous
edition but right now he has all he can
handle in nihonsaren
and if bortnick is ranked number nine i
think we know who number eight is he
might be playing him right now
yeah nihal a little bit higher rated but
this could but in the match could
swap so h5 is he trying to push his
pawns you know get
g4 at some point yeah a queen d3 i
do i don't think you want to trade
queens that's white but he's really
tempting you with queen d3
yeah so he just goes away queen a7 check
where's that look how exposed the king
is it rook c6
yep king on h2 is nice and safe and d5
d6 power yeah and rookie six i don't see
the
the wind just yet but it's looking
really good oh my god
look at these moves queen c4 and queen
a7 both sides are playing fantastic
right now
i just love the he's a bit ahead i love
that rookie seven but look at the clock
yeah white's a little bit ahead four
seconds from black fortnight needs to
move
he's hard to play if you get a checkmate
wow and i mean fornic has given that
side like
i'm he's not playing badly he's just got
his hands full with nihal sarin who is
a calculating machine robert well you
know in some ways that's
i think makes you feel worse because if
you're not playing badly and you're
still losing you don't have that mental
note of oh i can just correct this if
you're blundering pieces left and right
let's just not blunder here it's like
i'm playing well and nihal's up four
seconds and he checked maybe in the
final game
so what do you think bortnick has to do
to right the ship here
well i i sort of hinted at it before the
match that nihal is going to deliver
that more
solid consistent performance throughout
and i think that bortnik can play at a
higher level
when he's really feeling the tactics
when things are flowing but he's also
capable
of those blunders you know a little bit
more of a loose player which is kind of
part of his style as well so
honestly i i think he's stayed your
style here you don't change things up
especially in the middle of a
you know 15 more minutes of bullet chest
i think you just stick
to what you're good at and we know that
you know he
can win this match playing in his style
well we're going to be locked in but for
now we're going to take a quick breather
when we return we will have the second
half of the final match
of the wild card day here at the bullet
chest championship presented by sig
[Music]
and as you see here alexander bortnick
is not flying but one of his cameras
is he has the fair play cam above his
head so you know exactly what he's doing
on his computer he is just focused in on
the chest he's got the hydration station
right there
amman pretty cool that he has the setup
yeah he's got an awesome setup um
i mean i wish he would uh stream some
more for everyone out there because
he's got a sweet looking setup there
he's got all the uh all the apparel
all the equipment that he needs and he's
confirming to everyone who had that
question on their minds robert
yes indeed he is feet on the ground and
he is not flying anywhere
and he is just locked into the chest
getting ready for the next game and
this is the final match of the day
between nihal sarin and alexander
bortnick
both these superstars are trying to make
their way
to the quarterfinal only one can get
through
the winner will face andrew tang in the
quarter finals so both players trying
their best here it's very late for nihal
i was just thinking about that
i'm not exactly sure what time it is for
him but it's real late
yeah and and i always have that question
to myself we see the games getting
underway here
does that help or hurt the performance
because speaking for myself robert i
think it
honestly helped me i i'm a nocturnal guy
and i like playing
you know speedy you know dirty flag and
bullet chest at night
we all can't be nocturnal animals but
when we are we often
have good results so right here we see a
very locked up position closed
no pawn tension whatsoever i think that
black shouldn't be unhappy with the
position of the gates here but maybe
bishop takes h6 i wouldn't
count that out to watch out for that i
know sometimes the move like that
uh you can just well now i would really
consider it although knight g4 is
on the cards yeah so it was prevented
tactically but
it left it there and if you left there a
moment longer maybe it would have been
captured
right right and this knight on g3 i'm
not
so sure that it's where it wants to be
like i feel like we need a rerouting for
that night
yeah and when he goes b4 does niels
saunders trying to open up the queen
side and
he's first the king side seems oh he's
dropped his queen but he's attacking
white's queen in the process but way to
get me speechless there and neil
yeah and rook e3 just that that move
throwing it in there
well we're going to see h5 and we are h4
is a big threat here and if white plays
h was queen f4 for black that would have
won the h4 pawn directly
look it up that's a brave move rook to
e5 i can't believe it
because you can't play knight takes d7
unfortunately for black to pin that rook
so
uh i guess g4 and f6 is that is that too
much robert
that looks like too much i like the
intention though looks pretty cool
but i think it's too much and now just
rook back
and rookie three trade queens black is
better in the ensuing
ending but look at the clock about even
i think he was really considering queen
it takes h4 there which is why it took
so much time
but now that he's ended up trading that
time loss is very valuable for this time
scramble now
yeah he does win a pawn uh-oh okay he
saves the piece i thought he's gonna
lose the piece
black can make a draw like rook a2 rook
d2 and things like that but neil's
trying to win it
yeah no nino's down upon here but it's
just the coordination look how easy it
is for black to move pieces
bishop on d392 that they they're not
that easy to coordinate
and look at the time situation eight
seconds for white nine seconds for black
and now there's
oh look at that move thrown in because
the bishop's hanging on e2 wow
that's not only a good bullet move it's
just a damn good move period yeah that
was fantastic and now that paul's
promoting after you can't play rook d1
because the bishop covers and now queen
wow queen queen is leading to me i mean
he's going to throw that move
in but it's not going to be enough queen
g5 and there is going to be mate coming
up here
as niihau sauron just so calculated
feels like he has everything under
control even though it's a
time scramble with seconds and pieces
flying everywhere
this is weird to say but i think he
might be underrated
at nearly 3200. yeah yeah when nihal
gets
his style of game he he seems like he's
worth so much more than the rating he
has like
he's so calculated so controlled and you
can just see from the webcam there ultra
focus at all times and he's winning now
because
the threat was not just knight takes
pawn on e7 it was knight e7 check to
take the bishop to remove the front of
the knight and now
the knights hanging c5 will be hanging
the knight moves the rook's trapped
actually after bishop takes c5
right rookie one back look at this you
take on f8 you're up in exchange and
wow this is one-sided yeah this is i
mean even f4 if knight to e5 there f4
anyways
in the position looks like b3 c4 king up
great position f5 on my rook g4 maybe
here it comes
yeah rook g4 oh the bishop was trapped
the c8 trapped the bishop we didn't even
notice i was looking to trap the knight
i think we both
were a bishop now
i i know this is over but uh okay bishop
b7 might make it more apparent but
i was just gonna say you know four past
pawns in bullet they can be trickier
than you think
oh for sure g5 g4 coming your way this
still gives black a chance here those
pawns are more advanced and a pawn can't
go that quickly
yeah maybe rook c3 and then f4 is like
wait a minute
what's going on i like that move the
bishop if f4 maybe rook takes
e6 and then take h3 but a6 falls then
just bishop g2 and cover all the pawns
yeah it has to be
okay that was a good move though rookie
four was really really good but e5
oh and f3 you could play f3 there f3
there was rook g5 check there's rook
yeah wow
it's tough because sometimes you you you
think of rook g6 oh
piece trade i can do that not in this
case right
and well this looks like still a game
because of the time situation only eight
point six seconds
he just messed that up totally in the
rook g3
look at that rook the rook could have
blocked in the first rank or on the g
file and now
bortnick he gets his queen and he's up
on time and he's about to deliver
a checkmate yeah and some real signs of
emotion there
from nihal is probably going to see
queen b6 take the rook and that's the
simplest way to win
right now you can pre-move the pawn
promotion
king over enforce mates and that is
some real emotion as i said shown by
nihal sauron and that's a
big big mistake he dropped the bishop he
lost that game
where he was up a rook and what was i
saying robert how tricky are those pawns
in bullet
well tricky enough to win a game down a
rook and two seconds can make all the
difference you may think oh it's not a
big deal you have a piece
it's 12 seconds and 10 seconds who cares
well it matters because you start
pre-moving earlier when you have less
time
and then you drop pieces like that so
right now board nick with the white
piece he's going
full-on for the attack here
unfortunately i don't think his attack
is quick enough
and black's position looks quite stable
it does i'm waiting for the move knight
g3
um it goes knight c1 i'm assuming i was
missing something because knight g3 i
thought that's when that usually goes
bishop covers the c4 square and look at
that king f2
i i mentioned it earlier robert people
aren't really castling in 2021
no castling's overrated look at this
well actually if you are a learning
chestnut
no casting is important please castle
but if you're playing bullet chest you
can get away with things like this
because look at the castle king
you've castled into a potential attack
and that is why
bortnig is perfectly fine with his king
sitting where it is
right and h6 is going to be g6 which is
really
really nice solid structure king h8 to
get out of the way
and look all of a sudden bortnick is
like hey hey we remember that queen
trade let's let's do that thing
yeah but if you're trading queens and
the pawn h6 probably went too far it'll
likely be scooped up in
these ensuing end games and knight takes
a three as possible here they
don't see that knight d2 there's just
like pawns waiting to be taken at all
times here and i feel like that's a big
miss for nihil not to have gone for
those tactics
and look at bortnick stealing this pawn
if brooke ate there's knight c6 for
casey said there's beef
before hands c3 knight hangs the knight
yep so he's playing h7 here
because he's trying to think of what
move to play to save his knight he's
like all right check uh
how do i save my knight no you can't and
also you look how much
time king f4 i like this activate the
king
rook 87. just take out anything with
king f6 i'm a fan of that big fan of
that that would have been awesome
yeah there's no way i think white's king
is a rook b6
in this position you want to cover the
d6 square so the king doesn't get it so
actually rook
b6 as robert said it's a really good
idea 95 check can take the rook and f3
but too much time for black i i respect
the attempt though
i really do he's playing so well it's
just not enough
yeah and neil's just gonna flag him
that's
yeah all his focus is such a well-played
game by
nihal sarin and a really good attempt
from
bortnik he was down so much time dead
loss on the board i thought he gave a
really good showing but that's just
knee hell for you so solid doesn't give
you anything he's starting to flex and
there's five minutes 45 seconds
remaining in
this match which gives time for the
three games that
boric needs but he needs to win all the
games and he keeps going back to this
opening
has not been working out for him no i
think nihal's displayed
every time that they've played it that
the control of the d-file
even though he has the worst structure
is is worth it in bullet
and bishop b5 c4 bishop e8
your pieces are all dropping back but
black's pawn structure is better
because white is the threat that's true
and might play like h4
how do you get out of this for black i'm
trying to come up with any any idea
b3 i just i'm just going to go back to
e8
yeah now the other rooks coming to d8 oh
gosh
you can't move you can't move just
just politics yeah yeah because if you
ever leave the last frame there's rook
f8 bishop h6 ideas just
he's just taking everything that's being
put in front of him right now it's just
a dinner setting
so i do think this is the best that
bortnick could get so
right i mean good for him to get here
but now 97
times even yeah this is this should be
uh
should be over here bishop d6 yeah
bishop h
you have to play king g7 there and board
nick just sort of overlooked that
and now take on c4
oh wait no
he resigned but he could have won the
piece oh my god
i've never seen that before oh man
he thought he was gonna take the rook
and he saw the bishop moving he was
already clicking resign but he would
have won the bishop
okay so first of all the the pawn
to c5 was expected by bortnick so that's
why he went rook b4
he thought white was pushing the pawn
instead
he played for a before and hung the
bishop and bishop c5 neither
player knew what was going on and
meanwhile in this game it's practically
over as
oh my goodness it's over what what is
happening here
what b6 this is some kind of theoretical
i i think the theory says it should be
some kind of repetition and i don't
think king e2 is the right move
oh my god but for a bullet game it's
really smart to do this because now
you're up 30 seconds so unless
nihon mates him in the next bunch of
moves he's gonna win on time
well black just took a long time look at
50 seconds for bortnick make a quick
move f3 sure
yeah just go flag him knight e2
yeah no this is looking good for white i
can't belie like bartnik has to be
so tilted resigning a position where he
might even be the favorite to win
oh it's just painful and here well
speaking of favor to win it looks like
bournix upper rook is getting away with
it yeah g4 is gonna happen
oh that eval bar is swinging back and
forth so
oh goodness i think now now it's
increasingly clear that white is just
cruising yeah cruise control sarin is
down everything and all of a sudden at
the end of the day he's up
a rook and a piece yeah i think he can
manage this rookie one rook d2
knight c3 g3 same idea e4
hang on hang on uh the thing is he's up
on time
yeah way way too much for this to matter
but i think the match is pretty looking
pretty secure here
yeah that's two minutes 20 seconds
remaining and it's about to be a three
point
lead
that that is the moment of the match
king f4 that is the moment of the match
robert if you go back to that rook c4
moment
give that game to bortnick that this
whole thing flips around
yeah actually this would be a one-point
matches of three
yep wow wow
okay he was losing that game and i
pretty positive that you know mouse
slipped on that move
yeah a shame to resign after your
opponent's mouse that's how good the
mouse up was
wow g5 seeing it good this attack looks
good
wow this i mean he's in full sun moon i
don't blame him
but it's also working for bortnick like
maybe he should have gone full send mode
earlier
yeah if this is the type of stuff that
he's
slated to get then i agree with you
and just take on g7 you're up a pawn and
up
15 seconds on the clock that's a tricky
move though
knight b6 okay so he doesn't take on h4
and he's going to rook g8
no this looks i can't believe that white
didn't play knight takes d7
uh yeah me too loosen up the defense
there
now queen h4 is just next after queen
takes e3 so now you just take the queen
and
yeah this is a one-sided game ooh and
queen c5 just the icing
on top there just perfect play there
yeah
yeah it really was and so he's up a
queen for two minor pieces but look at
these pawns going the knight
is useless this promote and it's smart
of me hell not to resign
yeah as i often mentioned the players
never
are looking at the clock during the game
you know exactly so
he's just uh he he knows he may as well
play this on it looks like there will be
one
more game but not a game to change the
standings robert
no it's a two-point match right now
that's the spread and unfortunately for
bortnick he
really wishes he could take that
resignation back
yep because that's the that it literally
is the difference at the moment
and while he's showing his skill toward
down the stretch here
and if he wins this game i think they'll
be even on rating so
if fortnite can take this final game he
will say hey i'm
i'm his equal but i did lose this match
absolutely queen g4 looks like he's
trying to set up some knight
f knight h5 ideas with a bishop on e5 so
strong covering everything
yeah great move queen g5 by the way just
offering the queen trade knowing that
boarding
is going to try to win the game so he
avoids the queen trade and
well i think that black is
definitely defending office attack yeah
and honestly uh bortnick probably wants
to go for a win but the other
mindset is that he might know the match
is over and it draws okay
but it looks like he's still fighting he
went h4 he said
you know we could trade the queens in a
different manner here queen takes f4 g3
rook e1
things of that nature and can he get
this pawn on d4 that's the big question
right i'm i'm a little concerned for
that
knight on f5 getting trapped like g6
next
yeah now you should be concerned bishop
knight e7
yeah he gave himself that maybe bishop
a5
and d3 and rookie eight i guess
it doesn't make sense a bishop may have
heard this knight 66.
yeah that's a super important move i
feel like you should get something for
getting the knights to the other side it
doesn't happen all the time knight b6 an
episode threatened knight d7 check
this out that would be a family fork
oh that's bad key seven was just putting
material there
but they're playing the time scramble
and boarding ahead in the clock so he's
looking good to win this game better
pawn structure
more time and now extra pawn yep and we
see the rook go to b5
yeah i would throw in some checks i like
what he's doing oh we could take mg5 a
check but it doesn't
probably doesn't matter rookie six
rookie five oh okay i like that the
rookie three rookie h3
and even king f3 here yeah he's gonna
that's that's enough to flag that's
actually a really good flagging
technique
exceptional and we see oh neil
slightly higher rated than bortnick but
that was the last game so bortnick
wins three in a row to close out the
match and unfortunately for him
nihal was too strong in the middle of
this match
amman that was a really exciting affair
it sort of lost some of his luster when
neo started gaining the lead and
then i think bourneik didn't feel like
he was in it even though he clearly
still was
yeah he he looked a little deflated
and it was just that that huge moment
which we're obviously going to
see what nihal's thoughts on that are uh
in the interview but
that moment to me was the whole match
because bortnick as you see from the
final result
clearly capable of you know coming back
equalizing
hanging with nihal toe to toe the entire
match but it's just that single point
difference he just didn't have enough
time
to make the comeback because the lead
that nihil had from the beginning of
this match and especially in the middle
portion
it opened up to two three games and that
was just too much
certainly was the case and we will take
a short break when we return we will
bring anyhow on for an interview
you will definitely want to hear his
thoughts as he makes his way to the
quarterfinals of this bullet chess
championship presented by sig
[Music]
and we are back robert and myself joined
by the winner
of the match that we were just
entertained by mihal sarin
nihal i go over you for the first
question that i have on my mind which is
did you know at some point that the
match clock had expired and that you
uh were a point ahead going in because
going uh towards the end of that match
it seemed like bortnick was getting wins
and wins and wins and making a comeback
yes i was i was very happy in the last
match
so you so you were keeping an eye on the
match clock the entire time
no i did not really keep an eye on it i
was i was just trying to
play as good as possible and not look at
the clock
focus on the chest that's uh that's the
way to do it um
i think robert and i were all focused on
probably the moment of the match
which was uh when you play bishop c5
probably you'll you'll explain to us was
that a mouse slip
and then your opponent resigned it was
the craziest thing we've seen
yeah obviously it wasn't mostly if i
wanted to take the roof but i slipped on
the worst car possible
[Laughter]
and you know speaking of time yeah it's
pretty late by you it's past midnight
right so
do you like playing at the later hours
or
you know does it bother you at all to be
playing so late in the evening
i generally like playing in the later
house because
i think uh internet is generally better
and also there are not many disturbances
not many noises and stuff i am
comfortable staying
up late also that's uh that makes a lot
of sense it might be a
a young young player thing robert
because we actually saw
earlier in the match nihal i don't know
if you uh watched the earlier matches
as we saw arjun also uh qualify against
leveronian
he's also staying up a bit late and uh
just wondering if you
were up watching some of the matches
nice to see another indian player
qualify through
yes i saw all the matches
i didn't see much of maine versus lyric
but
other matches i saw well speaking of
other matches you are
have another match tomorrow you will be
playing against andrew tang
how many times do you think you played
against andrew online
uh i have played him quite a few times
not much on this side but
i have played him quite a quite a few
times and it will be a very tough match
for sure
so how are you feeling about tomorrow's
matchup then
i'll i'll just try to play a bit better
than today
just a bit better than how i finished
today
good idea if you're constantly playing
better than the last time you play it
then
i think that's a good recipe for
improvement
uh nihal obviously we extend our
congratulations to you uh you are moving
on playing andrew tangwood look forward
to
watching more of your games in the
bullet chest championship
but for now we'll let you go i know it
is late over there but thank you for
joining us and sharing your thoughts and
congrats again
thank you very much thanks danielle and
as you see here nia alsar moves on to
the quarterfinals he takes on
andrew tang in the bottom right hand
side of the bracket
the final eight are in place we will
have hikaru nakamura the top seed the
reigning champion
taking on arjun erigasi who defeated
lavonna ronin so he'll try to take
his second super grandmaster down the
road you have ali reza faruga taking on
vlad artemy of now that
is a heavyweight matchup of two
superstars in classical chess
blitz chess bullet chess rapid chess
whatever kind of chess you name
those are two players who will always
have a shot of the title
daniel naradicki takes on eric hanson
that's sort of the
streamer battle if you will two very
very popular content creators and
streamers
amman i'm not going to put you on the
spot this time because well it's eric
hanson playing
you don't need much more to say about
that and then nihal
sauron takes on andrew tang andrew of
course
known for his bullet prowess the guy has
been
lights out for years been blindfolded 15
second chess
but nihal he's you know he's young
he's ready for that action and he just
said i want to play better tomorrow
clearly he's hungry to improve his game
yeah i think nihal is someone that
people can easily underestimate in this
event i think he's
super super strong and has a really good
style for bullet chest which is
um you know maybe less rewarding less
flashy
he's not going to have those crazy
sacrifices but he's so quick
and so just calculated and controlled
that i feel like that consistent style
in a like a 30 minute match is very very
valuable so
look for him to progress in this
competition i think that match up
against tang
is pretty much a coin flip uh whereas
farouza and nakamura
you know find themselves as more
favorites going into those matches
yeah and even artemia have said as much
when he we asked him what he thought
about playing against el erisa he said
yeah he's gonna be the favorite but
he'll try his best so
we have four exciting matchups in store
tomorrow and before we go we still have
the trade of the day segment we would
like to show you
this presented by sig and it was i mean
a moment that we can't forget
right yeah no this is uh take you guys
back to what robert and i
found was the moment of the match and
especially the trade of the day we see
the liquidation here on f8 and bortnick
just forgot about this bishop d6 idea
um and after rook takes f8 i mean
those are the kind of trades you like in
life robert uh night for me and nothing
for you
risk free sounds good exactly rook b6
and here was the moment that rook d8 was
played now
probably expecting the move c5 bortnick
then played rook to b4
and as we heard nihil mention on the
broadcast bishop takes b4
doubtlessly his intention bishop c5
probably the worst
mouselit that you could come up with in
this position and instead of playing
rook takes c4
winning the bishop maybe going on to win
this game on time
come back in the match robert he
resigned the game
on the spot expecting his rook to be
taken it's one of those moments where
you tell everybody you can't win a game
that you've already lost
but at the same time there's that match
clock that you can't forget about so he
was resigning
to save time and unfortunately for
alexander bornick he could have saved
himself there by
winning the piece back but amman i mean
that's the type of day it was the type
of day it's probably going to be
tomorrow i am
super pumped for the quarterfinals if
that wild card round was any indication
we're about to have a wild time tomorrow
it's been exciting
a month always a pleasure having the
call with you i don't even know how to
wrap up the four matches that we just
saw
yeah it's been a truly incredible day uh
definitely a bit of a different
taste to bullet uh compared to the long
swiss qualifiers that we watched were
which were exciting in their own way we
were watching you know different games
from every player just trying to keep up
this i feel like it's almost felt like a
much slower pace even though we're still
playing bullet chess
it was some wild moves some fast moves
some crazy blunders
resigning in drawn positions or better
i felt like we got a little bit of
everything today and you know if niall
his comment was any indication that he
just wants to play better and better
chess every day
well that's what you can expect from the
bullet chest championships better and
better matchups every single day as we
get into
uh seeing some of those players that we
haven't seen yet hikaru nakamura daniel
narediski andrew tang
ali reza faruja will start to see those
guys matching up against our qualified
players
for sure we have so much fun left in
store and on behalf of chess.com and the
partners
from susquehanna international group i
thank everybody who's been tuning in
who's been supporting the broadcast
all the moderators the old chat the
community the producers you name it we
do appreciate you but i'm on our time
for the day has come to an end so
i'm going to say goodbye to you say
goodbye to the chat and please come back
tomorrow it starts a little bit later so
please keep that on your calendar
go to chess.com look at the news and
reminder before we go
it starts at 12 30 p.m pacific time it's
three and a half hours later
than it started today you will not want
to miss it
nope we'll see you guys then and for now
robert it's been a pleasure buddy we'll
uh be back with the calls tomorrow
[Music]
you